I do have three companies that make 100
million dollars a year these are all
bull uh this is from from Cal but go
ahead and just take this is a six figure
necklace and so what I want to do is I
want to give it to you and here's the
deal Jack
I got something for you bro
[Music]
what up primals the name is liver King
because liver is King welcome back to
the iced coffee Power Hour so far this
podcast has made the equivalent of one
million livers wow I'm gonna put a
currency on that though like USD how
much would one million livers be
equivalent to I love that you're asking
this right because you can't box me in
all right
um lever is the most valuable thing that
I know of right and real leadership is
seeing worth and potential in people and
in things and in opportunities that they
yet don't see in themselves this is what
I see in you guys this is part of the
reason why I was so excited to hook up
with you guys right because of the great
things that you're doing in the world so
what I'm really saying is like the value
that you guys are doing and the
potential that you have the kinetic
energy that you have is invaluable it's
immeasurable right so the most valuable
thing that I know is liver and we
brought some liver that we're gonna be
able to share here in a couple of
minutes so what's the currency that you
can put on that you can't box me in and
put a currency on that I would just say
it's the most valuable possible thing
sure well the current see on this
podcast is 267 thousand dollars
so we want to get into your story
because it's I mean it's a pretty well
known fact you're also an entrepreneur
you have multiple different businesses
and I mean I heard like a number thrown
around 100 million dollars in like you
know evaluation of your businesses or
something like that I want to know the
entrepreneurial side of things where you
started and how you got to where you are
now okay well I give you my word that
I'm going to answer that question right
after I tell you guys how appreciative
how grateful I am for you having me here
today right because I hear this all the
time hey thank you for coming hey thank
you for having me right I don't believe
it I don't buy it right I just want to
look you guys in the eye so that you can
feel what I feel right so I can put some
words to what thank you really means to
me because this is really what I stand
for this hearkens back to the question
that you asked before I did that
introduction it's really why do I exist
in life right it's because I'm the CEO
of the ancestral lifestyle because
people are living a life today of hurt
hate suffer struggle right people are
living with depression anxiety
autoimmune conditions infertility
there's a better life to live and you
guys know about this life because I know
you guys are living it of excitement is
full of Adventure it's full of light
love and laughter this is a life that's
worth living and so we can talk about
all the entrepreneur things but when I
say thank you for having me on I just so
desperately need you guys to be kicking
ass and doing what you're doing because
how is this message going to grow like
wildfire how are we going to get the
message out to go mainstream if I don't
have opportunities like this when I say
thank you those words that's precisely
what I mean thank you so much for coming
on it means a ton to us too as soon as
we saw that DM uh on our account I mean
like we just lit up we got super excited
did a ton of research and we could not
be more excited to have you on oh yeah
so I'll answer your question and I don't
mean to continue to dodge questions but
um the two most commonly questions uh
commonly asked questions I get it's
normally like how much do you left how
long have you been working out how much
money do you make and I'm like oh my God
like you trust me you don't even want to
hear this answer right if I tell you
I've been working out for 37 years which
is true it's like you guess what you're
not even gonna go try no you won't even
go work out for 20 years if you think if
you if I disagree I think people are
curious well I think it shows the
dedication and the consistency that's
required so I think the people that get
turned off from that wouldn't be
appreciative of your message to begin
with so I think you know it almost acts
like a filter well okay I'm glad you
pushed back I'm gonna give you a little
bit more context
um so you're right I do have three
companies that make a hundred million
dollars a year they're all high margin
companies I have more companies also
that are kicking ass but we'll focus on
these three I feel comfortable sharing a
whole lot of information about that what
I wish other people would ask is do you
lift enough weight to put yourself in
Unstoppable momentum right do you lift
enough weight to create the right types
of stimulus the right types of
adaptation to to live a growth and it
gains in an abundant mindset and if you
ask that question right because that's a
resounding yes how do you do it and why
do you do it this is what I want to hear
a lot more my why in the world is what
I've shared with you when we started
right it's people go to a job that they
hate they come home to a life that they
don't love they sedate themselves with
enough junk food with enough soda with
enough medication Netflix whatever right
call it a day called a week this is
their life right again this is my why
right I have kids that grow up going to
the hospital I don't know if you guys
did any research on this but my kids
couldn't breathe right they turn blue
like
does anyone here have kids you don't
have kids right no yeah what a horrific
feeling this is right when your kids
stop breathing they're turning blue you
give them an EpiPen it starts to help a
little bit but you don't even know how
it happened or how it's going to come
back this is my why in the world like we
figured this out it was my fault it was
it was what I was feeding them and and I
went to every doctor what did you feed
them I fed them the the standard the the
traditional American diet and I was
given I thought it was healthy because
it was from the whole thing they have an
allergic reaction or what what was the
cause we believe so that was the best
explanation that was an allergic
reaction to something that we don't know
okay
um and you never knew what it was going
to be they got hives from from our own
unless they're wheezing all the time
they couldn't breathe in life like it
was very rare that they could actually
take a full breath and this just became
normal right and so just by doing some
of these basic ancestral things
predominantly we just started with
eating we returned them back to nose to
tail eating the light bulb came on right
a personality was expressed that we
never knew they had right this is my why
in the world right this is why I do this
stuff and and how I do it is with the
liver King company right we went from
zero to six million followers in one
year and and we have 250 million
impressions a month right this is pretty
extraordinary right this is how I'm
doing it is by model teaching and
preaching this message so that it goes
mainstream I have these companies that
are kicking Us in life they're doing
three are doing 100 million a year right
but but if we look at the money really
money is a proxy for the value that we
create in the world right would you
would you agree right so money's just a
proxy for the value and so then I then
I'd normally say back okay so you
brought this up you wanted me to explain
these three companies 100 million which
we're starting to get into right after
10 minutes of the mouth enough so so now
we're getting into this and so I would
like to ask you back I want to get a
little bit deeper why do you ask why do
you care why do I ask I think it would
be really inspirational story where you
could talk about you know growing these
different businesses why you decided to
grow them like you just mentioned where
you were before what it took and then
that hopefully could Inspire some viewer
to do something similar with their
online we have a very entrepreneurial
audience who just wants to make money
they want to better themselves and so I
think hearing stories like this it's
always interesting I think it Peaks
people's curiosity to see what developed
it what started the idea how did you do
it because a lot of people think oh
maybe maybe you're naturally gifted from
the very beginning maybe you had this in
maybe you had a connection how did you
do it and hearing the stories from the
ground up just gives people a reason to
believe that you know there's more ways
to do something than just a standard
method put it that way yeah this is
exciting and I'm glad that how many
layers you went deep right it's not just
how much you make it's why do you do it
right how do you do it what it is that
you do because again we can talk about
it from a transactional standpoint I
think it's really easy to achieve people
end up making a ton of money they've
achieved they've achieved it and now
they have an empty life and that's why I
just think it's so important to make
sure that we pair hey how much money do
you make why do you do it why do you
create that kind of value in the world
how do you do it and then what is it
that you actually really do before we go
into that we gotta thank our sponsor
ftxus for those unaware they're one of
the largest US regulated cryptocurrency
exchanges in the world with millions of
users who buy sell track and trade both
crypto and nfts all in one place with
fees that are up to 85 lower than top
competitors seriously guys they've been
sponsoring this podcast for a super long
time and they help us do what we do for
you guys every single Sunday so it would
mean a lot if you guys checked them out
with that link Down Below in the
description it not only supports us but
also helps you guys out because they are
an amazing exchange we couldn't
recommend them anymore and plus they're
giving you all the way up to a hundred
dollars with the free crypto depending
on how much you trade when used link
Down Below in the description along with
free crypto and every single trade you
make over ten dollars plus buying crypto
is super easy all you have to do is
Select what you want to buy how much of
it you want to buy how often you want to
buy it and then swipe right and you're
done without any additional work on your
end and they also allow you to do
automatic recurring Buys so you guys can
invest exactly how we do and that's on a
recurring basis another really cool
thing is they're soon launching FTX
stocks where you're going to be able to
trade stocks crypto and nfts all in one
platform with super low fees trust me
guys you're going to want to check it
out so help support the podcast and also
trade on an exchange that charges you
very low fees with the link Down Below
in the description it means a lot thank
you guys so much and back to the podcast
let's start at the beginning okay okay
so first off just to lay the foundation
down where were you born what was like
childhood like yeah and then let's move
on to like high school and like were you
an academic person potentially College
yeah all that was uh uh I'm just
thinking was an academic person I was
just trying to survive days you know um
so I guess we'll get to that I was born
on a naval air station in Seva Puerto
Rico I come from a military family my
dad died before I had a memory of of him
as he was serving and um and so we're
stationed in San Antonio at the time and
um I just remember Elementary School was
amazing I loved Elementary School
um it's not that I had friends in
elementary school but I came home and I
had friends that lived up the street
that was pretty cool
um and uh I think this is where business
actually started at eight years old I
figured out that you could start selling
in candy on the street and I would buy
it for probably 50 cents a bar and I
would sell it for 60 cents you know but
uh but with enough of that I was like oh
I'm starting to make money and I don't
know if you guys remember
um Sam's Club came out and now you could
buy a whole box of them and now you
could buy them for like 20 cents a bar
and sell them still for 60 cents and
people would call me and I would deliver
it to them and I loved it right like
this gave me some confidence and so I
remember now going to middle school
middle school was horrific I got this
[ __ ] kicked out of me every single day
um and I think that this is what really
helped me get through I did work out so
I could control some outcomes in my life
that made me feel good but I also saw a
lot of entrepreneurial opportunities I
had a friend Peter who said hey you want
to go sell newspapers with me it's like
what does that involve and uh and it was
newspaper subscriptions and I'll never
forget the first time I went some grown
man was taking us 10 year olds around
dropping us somewhere on the other side
of town and I remember Peter's first
pitch you know he knocked on the door
and it was excuse me ma'am you currently
subscribed to the San Antonio light
which is no longer a business you
currently subscribe to this we just
would like for you to renew your
subscription we want to give it to you
absolutely free I was like how is this
going to work and she starts signing and
goes all you have to do is pay for
Sunday Sunday 75 cents and she's like oh
hey you caught me this isn't going to
work out you know we're not going to
renew and the peer said ma'am would it
be okay if I just got a glass of water
could you give me a glass of water she
would invite us in we're little kids she
would invite us then give us a glass of
water he would ask about a picture or
something in the house and he would say
hey man we're just trying to make a
couple of bucks right if you're not
going to do it for you think you could
help us out and almost all the time it
worked out but here's where we really
made the money is at the end of the day
we're waiting for this adult man to come
pick us up in the van and and we just
got to be there let's say he says you
got to be there between three and four
well you better be there 2 45. he
normally picked you up at five so no we
got like two hours of dead time this is
where we really made our money was kind
of panhandling at the gas station at the
pickup point right we're Sweating
Bullets because it's summertime and then
as the customers would walk out of the
7-Eleven or whatever excuse me sir it's
really hot outside could you spare 15
cents so that we could get a cold
beverage and you almost got it almost
always got a quarter or a dollar
whatever that was right and so I think
early on I started to see some of these
things I'll tell you this one last story
when I was in Middle School I started to
figure out did you guys ever see people
that would do pencil fighting now what
is that so you you hold I wish we had
pencils it would be so cool to do this
you hold one pencil like this right and
your opponent is holding his other
pencil and he's he's trying to break
your pencil when you hold it like that
right and and of course if your pencil
breaks and you lose right and it gets so
popular that now people are saying hey
man I'll buy your pencil from you and so
people are buying pencils for 25 cents
right because because of how competitive
and all the testosterone going on and um
so of course I saw that as an
opportunity I went to the 99 cent store
and I bought a bag of pencils for a
dollar it's so damn it's like five sets
of pencil I can sell it for 25 cents and
um and the number one problem in pencil
fighting is the Eraser would fall off
there's like this metal clasp I took
duct tape but just a little sliver of
duct tape to secure that eraser and and
I could differentiate my pencils from
everybody else's pencils and I would
sell out pencils and I would come home
with all these quarters and and again
like I got the [ __ ] kicked out of me
almost every day and half the time
people did take my money but I felt like
a million bucks that I figured some of
this stuff out that I could control
these outcomes in my life and this is
what I'm talking about some of these
opportunities when you're younger right
when we're not distracted by the phone
what the mind can do what the mind can
invent right what the mind can even see
so this is pretty much my upbringing in
San Antonio
um oh sorry I didn't want to interrupt I
was just going to ask why do you think
they picked you to bully oh I know why I
was the only one of my kind nobody
looked the way I looked I was the only
white guy at school I was the only white
guy at school
um and uh I was Tiny I mean even going
into uh High School I was under five
foot tall and so Middle School I was
really short and I was really short I
was really little I had no concept of
self-worth I was completely embarrassed
like I would look at myself and the way
I dressed the way I looked you know in
elementary school I don't think it ever
occurred to me you know to look at
myself like that and then when you're
called all these Dames and and then
people can manhandle you and you've
never stood up for yourself and you
don't have a dad to put his arm around
you and say hey man punch that guy back
in the face stand up for yourself you
know do something I never did any of it
so I mean I I could say like I was an
easy target but I was the easiest Target
I was Tiny I was little I was the only
one of my kind I took it you know and so
this is just what happened you know for
about four or five years from about 10
or 11 to about 15 years old is what
happened and how did that shape you in
your life what did it change I would say
it forged me into the evolutionary
hunter that I am today right you know
what I'm so glad that you asked that
because people when I tell it's like oh
this is a sad story right I couldn't be
more grateful for those years this was
my first rite of passage you know I
would say most people never actually
have a legitimate rite of passage in
their life so this was the hardest thing
that I've ever been through at that time
in my life and um for a long time I was
almost embarrassed to tell my kids about
it I was embarrassed to tell my kids
about that and then I realized like this
is what gave me the strength this is
what gave me my first rite of passage my
first true struggle that I overcame that
I saw I was able to claw my way out of
that myself right and then when you
start to figure out those things on your
own right this is what forges your
character yeah so I couldn't be more
grateful you know what kind of value did
I get out of that I mean determination
resilience robustness you know
um when I saw that I got myself out of
it like extreme ownership real
leadership you know I figured figured
out that I could actually control and
create the life that I actually want to
live in and it made me work out harder
and then one day I actually figured out
what real strength is right now when you
can impose that kind of forces well not
just physically but mentally
intellectually right like people say oh
I'm the most dangerous man in the room
and I start cracking up like well I
would say you certainly are in this room
currently yeah yeah but I wouldn't pick
a fight with you you could take all of
us on at once oh I know that because I
do that actually all the time but but
this is actually my point right the most
dangerous man in the room is not the
strongest guy in the room right because
people I hear people say this oh yeah
this is my goal to be the most dangerous
man in the room like what does that mean
right oh because I'm like this far in
Jiu Jitsu you know because I'm this
proficient like with without with the
firearms and stuff like that like okay
cool you're a warrior right but like
what a real king does right is he's able
to achieve his outcome right he's able
to unite he's able to provide a cause
for a fight and unite and that's the
most dangerous guy in the room right so
I started to figure out like the the
physical part that that came pretty
early I I didn't figure out I would say
14 team start working out then no I
started working out at eight eight or
nine how at nine years old did you go
start working out like what did you use
yeah my mom's boyfriend sir there was
Michael gleinsner okay he gave me uh a
bench he's like I got this old bench I'm
sure he saw something in me hey do you
want it it was all
it was horrific it was falling apart it
was Rusty cobwebs
I loved it you know and I I was just
drawn to it I think we're drawn to work
you know and then when you work we're
wired this way when you fight overcome
and persevere you get rewarded with a
boot with a boost of androgens and
dopamine to do more of the same he gave
me this stuff I started to do it and I
loved it I never stopped doing it I
remained pretty small height wise but I
remember I started to like build the
chest and I would take my shirt off
every time I had the opportunity nobody
really cared for a while but then people
started to care at about 14. at about 14
I heard somebody say I've told this
story before but somebody said you look
like Marky Mark
I couldn't believe it I couldn't believe
it it changed my life probably I mean
really no joke I would it made my day it
made my year maybe made my life so I
went back and I doubled down on
everything and then people would ask me
all the time I could see that my peers
wanted to be like me and for the first
time ever girl started to notice me so
about that age I started to realize that
I had some I had physical strength but
when you start to figure out the
strength socially emotionally mentally
and spiritually like from a holistic
level I think that's where the danger
comes from right when I say danger
effective right when you're the the most
physically dominating man okay are you
dangerous sure you're not the most
dangerous man in the room right like a
true king can achieve those outcomes
that he wants to see in the world
without fighting right and that's a
warrior archetype so that that's kind of
what I figured out at around that age
but if you want to talk about grades my
grades were horrific
my grade I didn't study anything I
didn't study a single day for anything
but well for first of all for five years
I was trying to figure out how to
survive sure I mean I would get punched
and I would just wake up and the bell
had already rung and I was like okay it
happened again right you I mean you
punched knocked out you wake up okay
gotta okay what time the teacher's not
doing anything oh my God no dude if the
teachers would break up a fight they
would get handed to this serious at the
end the only one that would break up
fights would be the coaches and then the
coaches would come from halfway across
the campus and so by that time
everybody's bloody and there's gangs and
people brought guns to school back then
steel toe boots and guns so all I cared
about was trying to survive really back
then like I don't give a [ __ ] about
grades and so I continue to not give a
[ __ ] about grades until
um my mom said hey you got to take the
SAT I'm like okay I'll take that say t I
swear to God I cheated with a person
next to me of course I think I knew that
the questions were different but it was
the best that I knew to do I mean I
didn't understand it interesting on this
thing um my mom really forced me to go
to college to go to Community College I
couldn't get into any college I got to a
community college but this is this is
the truth you guys are going to love
this
um oh they're all remedial classes all
of them and um
the students in there next to me they
couldn't speak English so I'm starting
to realize I'm doing math and reading
and these basic you know uh subjects
with people that can't speak English I
think to myself holy [ __ ]
like you know at the time it's Brian I'm
so I'm so wired to say and liver King
thinks this right but Brian thinks oh my
God you're better than this man like you
gotta do better you got to be better so
I took things seriously I took him so
seriously that um I've made Straight A's
from then on I got a full ride I got
into an actual College I got into Texas
Tech University I got a full academic
scholarship I graduated with a 3.92 GPA
I did an undergraduate thesis in
Biochemistry
um so I got my shoulder right but I mean
I do nothing you know and so my kids are
homeschooled they're self-taught right
now and so sometimes you know the
friends will come over that they know
physics you know that they they know
like some legitimate you know
stuff and sometimes every Queen is like
hey does that ever worry you and I'm
like does that worry me listen I went to
18 years old before I started to study
some of that stuff but let me tell you
the value that we're creating in our
boys right like we we've brought them
into everything that I do I don't go
anywhere without them so again thank you
for being uh so gracious to host them
here too because I don't go anywhere
without my family they've been to the
Amazon they've been to Africa this year
we're going to Mongolia and Dubai next
month right
um all the business conversations I have
they're brought into that right so it's
like the the I feel like the upbringing
that they're getting right now is pretty
profound sure that's important to me so
um I didn't care about grades until I
had to care about grades
um and and then when I cared about
grades you know I I listen I know I
don't have the highest IQ in the room
but I know that the the my the students
next to me were smart and they were all
going to take the MCAT and they were all
going to get into medical school and I'm
just scared as [ __ ] oh my god this is my
competition so while you guys are going
to frat parties or doing anything I'm
home and I'm studying and I'm figuring
out how to be resourceful how to get the
A's that I need to get so number one I
can continue with the income with a
scholarship that I have and number two
so I can get into medical school so
that's sort of my my uh my upbringing up
into to college that that's what
happened and when did Brian turn into
liver King how did you do it and why I'm
curious if what the first job you had is
yeah the first professional joke yeah is
it right out of college I was 21 years
old and I learned about a pharmaceutical
rep I learned what that was because
meanwhile I'm I'm doing this undergrad
thesis so that I can go to a Texas Tech
Medical School Branch otherwise why
would you undertake such an Endeavor
this is like I had to get a you know a
board a committee I mean I can't tell
you how many hours you know research and
effort went into this and then I
realized um I didn't have any any idea
what I wanted to do I was at an
orientation everybody had gray hair half
of them were engineers and I'm thinking
holy [ __ ] I'm 21 years old and and I
started asking questions what do you
doing here and half of them were
switching their careers at this stage in
their life and I started thinking oh my
god I've never thought about this my mom
chose my curriculum for me my my dad was
in medicine he was a veterinarian and so
I started thinking uh I don't know what
I'm gonna do and then this just happened
by the grace it was like Hey so my
friend is a pharmaceutical rep and
here's how much money she makes and all
I knew is like I love to snowboard I
love to travel I don't think that's
inexpensive hey I'm a go doof I'm gonna
go do that thing sure and so I started
to do that thing and I loved it I I felt
like I had my own territory at the time
they only hired a pharmacist to do it
it's like you have older people doing
this job and this is when I really first
learned if you really want to exceed in
life it's the easiest thing that you
have to do all you gotta do is work
because nobody's actually willing to
work you know it all you got to do is
show up and work it blew my mind I mean
the first year and these guys do all the
mechanisms of actions they're all
Pharmacists and and I remember coming in
and at first okay we're all competing
for the same doctor's offices at first
right and and then I said okay I'm gonna
show up earlier and I'm gonna show up
earlier I'm gonna show up earlier and I
started showing up at four o'clock four
a.m and meeting doctors when they would
go and do the rounds and I would bring
their kolaches and whatever and at first
it would never give me time then they
would start laughing oh my God Johnson
you got to get out of here and then they
would start laughing and be like okay
you should and I would I would just
throw darts you know I'd be like hey let
me bring you a different breakfast hey
here's where I can provide value hey I
bet I can help you lose 80 pounds oh
okay you got me okay meet me here 15
minutes early every time right and and
then what I realized is most of the
pharmaceutical reps would go home early
and then all I had to do was stay right
a couple more hours and there was Zero
competition trying to get into these
places and and then a lot of people
would take Fridays off I mean I'm
telling you I I've found this out across
across every category
um I think that a lot of people say that
they want to work hard and a lot of
people do right but I think for the most
part if you want to immediately separate
yourself you commit to real legitimate
Massive Action and that in and of itself
is going to really help you this this
was my first job as a pharmaceutical rep
then I got into device sales it's called
the Neurosurgical consultant we would do
uh help neurosurgeons learn method
patented procedures
um I thought that was a cool job for a
little while then I met liver Queen I
met her snowboarding and she was a
dentist and I was like oh this is
awesome you know because
um she was fun she was by herself so she
had her nephew with her
um but uh it's like oh this is my
opportunity I mean I knew the minute I
met her that she was my soulmate how did
you meet her exactly where's
snowboarding uh so so she I was riding
up a lift I was with my my best friend
at the time at that stage of my life
best man in the each other's weddings
his name is Jeff Parchman we're on a
lift together on a chair lift it's his
first time going up the mountain and I'm
probably about 150 yards in front of me
I see her snapping on her snowboard and
all I see is a ponytail and a helmet
she's wearing goggles right but like
this is what I figured out in life this
is work hard right I mean how many
people are gonna go take that rep I mean
I've taken that rep I already had a date
set up that day right because I had
already taken that many reps and so this
was another rep and and she didn't give
me the time of day she kept snowboarding
she I don't she says that she didn't
hear me but
um then I caught her in the lift line
and I just said Hey where's the rest of
your crew and she said oh my nephew he's
in he's in ski school and I'm like oh
cool that means he liked me and I said I
know this mountain let me show you
around and I mean as soon as we got into
the chairlift and I saw her face and I
looked into her eyes I could feel I knew
this I never been in a real serious
relationship in my life so we got
engaged in like six or seven weeks we
got married like a couple months after
that right now that was 18 years ago and
so immediately
um when I learned that her background
was in dentistry and and she moved to
Texas she said hey I want to go you know
work for this kind of practice and there
was a few weeks I went by and uh she was
having a little bit of trouble doing
what because she was the bomb in New
York City she was in like really
successful practices there doing great
things and I said well why don't we
start a business and so we vertically
integrated we we bought dental practice
we vertically integrated that and we
started business there and so that's
really where
um I went from a couple of kind of
corporate jobs to I'm going to go in on
this all in on this full-time and let's
let's just talk about those first couple
of jobs real quick how much were you
making at each job and then talking
about you know potentially how you
scaled that Dentistry business yeah I
couldn't believe it 21 year old making
like a hundred thousand dollars yeah and
I mean because pharmaceutical sales pay
really well yeah if you're good at it
you could make a ton of money what even
is a fart like do you are you the person
that I remember that this is also back
in like yeah 1999. this is like when I
was born it was like a lot oh this is a
while back and um and I couldn't believe
it they were going to give me that much
money and they were going to give me a
they gave me a company car they gave me
uh cell phones had just come out I was
getting a cell phone I was getting a gun
you David I couldn't believe it and they
would give me a relocation allowance to
put down on a house and I couldn't
believe it like I'm telling you you know
I mean I just what this did for my
confidence you know like I needed this
and what they basically said is hey
here's a 2 million dollar Territory go
grow it and then we're gonna bonus you
incentivize you on that and then when I
realize oh all it takes is hard work a
little bit of Ingenuity you know I had
presidents Club on the first year really
just by working hard right and I
remember oftentimes like doctors would
challenge you right
um and they would ask you okay what's
the mechanism of action here what's a
detox pathway and I remember
um oh I'm not really sure what that is
if you give me five minutes I'll have a
definitive answer for you and I'll knock
it out of the park and I'm going to
provide unequivocal value I'm not giving
you five minutes I gotta go see patience
you're done I never respect you again
that's what they said with their eyes
right so I'm back to the car and I would
read the package insert I would call the
clinical team and then I learned about
all the cytochrome p450 pathways you
name it so the next time somebody asked
me that like oh that's not happening
again right so as a pharmaceutical rep
it's really all about influence right
it's about getting time with a doctor
basically to to say why your drug is
better than another drug or maybe even
change a paradigm to say Hey you have
patients that are exhibiting these
symptoms agitation dementia yada yada
yada you know maybe uh they have
intractable depression here's a drug
that you can consider using that's on
label sometimes off-label use it's not
indicated but hey your peers are doing
this too if you're having trouble with
those kind of patients you might
consider this drug and you would say
your drug three times right you would
say the neighbor you're drug three times
at the beginning middle it ended and you
never set the competitor no matter what
and this is why I say never King here
this is what liver Kings have for dinner
liver King yada liver King out this is
why I do what I do right because you're
going to hear my name three times
because liver is King right because
because you know my why because I got to
be effective at my job to do what I'm
gonna do so that's what pharmaceutical
reps do um that's what I was making at
that time I think when I left doing that
it was about 120 I made double that as a
device rep and and this was known like
this kind of like the trajectory if you
kick ass in Pharma you can get into
devices you can maybe sell pacemakers uh
neuromodulators you could sell like MRI
machines and you can make 250 300 000
doing that so when we met she was making
about 250 000 a year I was making about
250 000 a year and we're like hey let's
combine forces yeah let's buy dental
practice and then uh and so we we turned
um a practice I was doing 400 000 a year
into within one year was doing 1.2
within three years it was doing 5.2 and
so what do you credit that to how did
you do that you know um
really it's such a low hanging fruit you
know like most most lawyers are out of
the curve but Most accountants doctors
dentists you they don't know anything
about business they know very little
about business right and so all it took
was like looking at the books and then
seeing I'm like oh those are a lot of
bills who are those bills going to oh
we're referring you know over to these
guys we're referring over to this
Imaging Center Wilson radiographic oh
cool how much does it cost to buy MRI
machine it's not that much oh we're
paying all these bills over the dental
lab how much does it cost to start our
own dental lab well it's not that much
right so we started to vertically
integrate all all the stuff that it's
all first principles thing and I had no
background really in business other than
the experience right I think people
really undervalue first principle
thinking right and just getting to work
because I tell people this all the time
I was on the uh Alex hormones you
wouldn't give me the time of day and
then he gave me the time of day and we
started talking and said hey how are you
successful I'm like you know how I'm
successful all I do is shoot shoot shoot
aim shoot shoot shoot right I take such
Massive Action that these guys that are
tedx smarter than me they're still
coming up with strategy all I'm doing is
taking massive action and course
correcting along the way of course I've
made mistakes along the way this is what
I attribute it to is really Massive
Action first principle of thinking right
normally a hire a consultant when I
heard the consultant I'm like that's
exactly what I'm not going to do because
this is what everybody knows to do right
he might provide some insight but almost
always I asked my first principle of
thing and type questions oh no you can't
people don't buy dental Labs that are
dentists you know oh no people don't do
imaging centers that are dentists that's
real interesting because you know half
the time we don't get the radiograss
back anyways right so now the patient
care and continuity is in the basement
right you're sending somebody over to
this oral surgeon to get a tooth
extracted to get an implant placed right
and now what's happening is the
patient's coming over here there's an
infection we can't place the crown over
the tooth or the abutment send it back
to the oral surgeon bouncing back and
forth between three or four doctors and
so we said you know we're referring all
this business out we refer two billion
dollars out to oral surgery like in the
first you know what we didn't but the
the previous uh doctor had why don't we
just bring all that in-house and why
don't we just pay a percent to these
guys so we we brought in every
discipline of Dentistry we built the
first vertically integrated Dental
Center that had all disciplines of
dentistry and again this is just like
basic thinking right I guarantee you
everyone here could figure that out and
and so we called it dentique Dentistry
it was the first vertically integrated
Boutique Dental Center and you could get
comprehensive care there and so that
that's uh that's what we did there and
um it was fun doing it but the truth is
it wasn't really our fight you know um
my my wife had uh this degree you know
she had gone to school for over a decade
and it's almost like she had locked
herself into that and she was able to do
incredible things full mouth
reconstructions you know stuff that
other people couldn't do it was
incredible stuff she would come here to
Las Vegas to lvi Institute to get
trained to do these full mouth
rehabilitations and people would fly
from all over the country all over the
world and they would pre-pay up front
from they would wire the money in from
another country to come get the work
done and I'm talking 80 90 dollar cases
there's the opportunity in dentistry is
incredible right this is oral health
this was really never her fight though
this was never really my fight it was it
was an interesting opportunity right
that kind of fell in our lap and so we
did this for about a decade and and then
we started to figure out like how to get
our kids healthy right and when we
figured out how to get our kids healthy
like this whole ancestral living thing
we started to figure out why people have
oral health issues right and and I don't
know I started saying this thing because
we got this company that we're quietly
launching it's called strongja and the
motto is our early ancestors didn't
brush didn't floss and didn't get
cavities so how come the more we brush
the more we floss the more cavities the
more recurrent Decay we're getting today
there's another solution here right it's
how you nourish yourself predominantly
the fat soluble vitamins liver bone
marrow egg yolks get some midday Sun
mechanically load the teeth today we
like to eat things that fall off the
bone we're like babies we like to eat
things that fall off the bone that are
all mushy you know I ask people hey what
are your favorite foods unlike mashed
potatoes right I like I like fall off
the bone this thing you know I'm like oh
you're like a baby you're like a baby
this is to our detriment right and so uh
liver Queen starts saying okay like we
gotta educate our patients right because
we got to treat the root cause because
she has the biggest heart you guys and
um and a lot of patients were like hey I
don't want to hear this is nutrition I
can't you just fix my teeth and then the
Associates at the practice and now that
the practice is incredible right but I
remember at the time I was like hey
don't do this thing you're going to put
me out of business but this is how it
evolved it was never really our fight
and then when it became our fight you're
talking about changing a complete
Paradigm right people actually think the
more you floss the more you brush the
the more better your dental health is
going to be right until you nourish
yourself from the inside out it's how
you mechanically load your teeth uh
what's so funny what are you laughing at
over here I see ya man oh it's here
oh my oh wait what is that here we have
a chicory board with some of the organs
that are early ancestors eight that we
don't eat anymore
yeah so here we have are going to be the
organs that our early ancestors used to
eat that we kind of straight away from
eating anymore we're gonna have some
kidney pancreas some hearts testicles
bone marrow and of course the king of
the organs liver
what is this one that's a testicle
how did you get my testicle on there
no don't you dare Graham this is really
telling right because you and I were
like well we know what that is because
we got two of them and you're like what
is that hey but it's yeah but you're
only 20. would you tell me you don't
have a pair of those this no I certainly
do not have a pair of that man listen
you're only 24. your your beard is still
coming in you know but here's the thing
this this is the most valuable stuff
that I know how to share in gift and and
I would love to be able to share some of
this stuff with you guys all right so
I'm gonna get some Bureau I initially
said uh because I knew you're gonna do
this I initially I didn't want to try
this uh I'll be open to it I'll be open
to the idea I really didn't want this
well thank you so much for being open to
the idea I get queased out by the way I
don't eat it sounds ridiculous I don't
eat meat on the bone
how come uh I get weirded out by it
because I can't separate the thought of
the animal from what I'm eating so it's
like chicken I'll eat a chicken breast
if it's not on the bone steak
I don't like the bone on it yeah
it just irks my stomach
you know it's just it's it's something I
think of the animal and I you know and I
love meat I love steak I love fish but
when I see the face when I see the bone
it just makes it too real for me there's
not a better time to conquer that fear
than now bro live on the podcast try it
but I know where I would like to start
what about you guys I'd say we start
easy and then slowly amp it up I'm
assuming that means testicles last oh no
right I want you to I want you to First
tell us at what point did you become
liver King where did that start yeah
um it was during that Dental model when
the queen was trying to bring
nourishment into treating her patients
there was a lot of resistance to that
and we learned how to get our kids
healthy right and then we learned how to
kick ass
um so so liver Queen's like hey I'm done
I'm retiring and so when she retired
part of my thought was in business I'm
like oh my God you know
um the higher up you go in business the
more bosses you have right I remember
early on like oh I got bosses in the
corporate world but I want to own my own
business when I'm on my own business I'm
going to be my own boss but every
patient that came in with my my boss
right and and really I just wanted to be
like my truest honest self I didn't want
to have to adapt to anybody else's you
know character or any of that stuff long
story short you know when I got my kids
healthy I kind of made a promise that
I'm Gonna Be My truest most authentic
self and when I figured that out and I
had done enough barbarians when you do
the Barbarian we'll talk more about that
later I hope
um your your Primal truest most
authentic form comes out it's wild it's
freeing it's like you're always having a
party you don't ever need a drink you
guys when your best friends when you're
around each other right again the
culture the chemistry the electricity
that you have right this is not the same
when you go and meet with a stranger
right but what if you could let your
guard down the same what if you could be
that vulnerable that authentic and other
people could see the value of that and
so that's when I became the liver King I
was like you know what this guy's come
out enough he's tasted enough of what it
feels like to be a barbarian that
corporate guy I'm never going back to
that corporate guy ever again love me or
hate me and I get a lot of both Love Me
Or Hate Me liver King is the only guy
that's moving forward the predecessor is
gone all right we gotta get this out of
the way
I can't concentrate okay yeah all right
what are we starting I don't want to
know about it
I forgot what that stuff is I just want
to eat it okay I just want to get it
over let's start let's start with one of
these yeah don't tell me what it is
until afterwards please got it uh my
buddy uh is from Iran and he had me eat
a chicken heart as soon as I figured out
what it was I almost threw up Graham so
I'm proud of you man yeah I'm really
happy you're branching out and trying
something new you're gonna be happy you
did this in the future yeah boxing
people are gonna call me out on this
just out of here that click is that our
camera okay good all right yeah cool so
how do we eat you eat this with your
fingers I mean are we not like that's
Primal we're not doing like I'm Primal
yeah
when I came in you you guys weren't even
rocking shirts we're wearing our bare
feet we're pretty Primal so let's go
ahead and start right here I won't say
what it is let's start right here okay
come on Graham grab a piece see you can
see this right here in that camera
Cheers Cheers come on Grandma I'll wait
for you Grandma yeah let's do it grab
the big one
should I chew it or do you just kind of
swallow I like to chew it it's up to you
cheers
oh it's chewy
that's not bad at all
I I use the chewy bit right there it's
okay
and here's the deal
normally we bring a subprimal spit
bucket you guys didn't bring the sub
problem
I don't need a subprimal spit bucket I
know you crushed it thanks you did in
Graham's defense I really think he got a
piece of connective tissue in there too
and then when you get that it because
normally this is kind of like a like
maybe just a tougher piece of Sashimi
yeah it tastes like Sashimi Graham try
and try one without a connection I
listen I ate half of that all right you
got the taste of it you got some
nourishment in it um let's go ahead and
move on well I know what that is well
don't say it don't say it okay this is
actually probably the most mild of them
all a lot of people think this tastes
like like uh salmon oh no okay
okay all right
y team cheers cheers cheers
it tastes just like a clam
just like a scallopy yeah yeah a lot of
people compared to that okay cool let's
move it along then okay okay you're
doing great so far man really really
proud of you man good job it's like an
episode of Fear Factor okay what's next
this guy yeah let's do it okay
um
I'm happy I got past that one
that one yeah all right cheers non-fatty
looking piece oh wow
very mild right
that just tastes like steak
obviously like there's a lot there's a
hint of blood on all of them but that
tastes just like steak so yeah I put a
tiny bit of fish sauce on that it's like
it's delicious yeah that one looks the
least appealing for sure you don't like
brain I'm just kidding that's not right
I was gonna say I wasn't gonna break the
rule plus we wouldn't bring you guys
Brian go ahead let's uh
wow that's it guys I don't want it to
drop so I'm gonna go put it down the
hatch
all right
I hope I can eat that man
liver King Chef Lionel it tastes the
same as everything the best pieces for
us the highest quality best pieces all
right
you're okay got it Graham get it down
that is a level of concentration I've
never seen on Grand before Graham I
think you crushed that one my man the
mental strength on that one was
very I was yeah very clear uh this last
one let's do this one so I watched you
go on a few
Alex I want you to do this yeah yeah
I watched you go on a few other podcasts
made it seem like it was a big deal to
eat this stuff but realistically this is
not bad it's not tough it just tastes
like so glad that you said that because
this is one of the biggest things that I
want people to know and do right I I
want I know that you have you have an
issue uh with the animal Graham and um
you know a lot of people I know that
have gone on a hunt have established a
new connection
this one I would just swallow man I
would swallow it fast
was that that one yeah
yeah I'm gonna share why that one's
tough I'm guessing it's it's kidney pee
yeah yeah
I was about to say it was really salty
yeah it tasted like pea this one's
always tough for that reason the the
this is pancreas which is usually tough
because of the consistency right then
you have heart which is really delicious
and Mild but you have elastin and
they're in a lot of collagen you get
that connective tissue it's like gum
you're gonna be chewing that all day and
you probably know that this one is
testicle like you said really mild
almost like a scallop or something and
then this is this is a king this is
liver right here this was filtering
blood just this morning so it's actually
really fresh
so this morning this stuff is really
fresh this morning yeah
where did you uh where'd you get this
from
um this is this is liver King Chef
Lionel's thing he either gets it from
liver King Ranch or he gets it from
somebody local or he'll overnight it but
this is a really important thing is to
make sure that the the organs that
you're getting you really know the
source of it right and if you know this
Source if it's that fresh and it hasn't
exchanged that many hands this is a
great thing you can it's like sushi it's
like Sashimi right if that's not the
case you should really freeze it for a
couple of weeks to decrease the the
pathogenic load but this is really fresh
and I know that liver King Chef Lionel
just adheres to the the highest like
quality standard so because if we give
you a bad experience you know you're
gonna have PTSD with it I would like uh
Alex do you want to do the honors do you
want what about the bone marrow how do
we eat that yeah how do we get on the
bummer or anybody bring a spoon
I'm glad that you asked because my big
things are like you got to get down on
liver and bone marrow yeah these are
like the fundamental things I think
honestly the heart's the best tasting
one I agree yeah they're from all of
that liver's not bad either I kind of
like it good I feel like I should
capitalize on my opportunity to eat yeah
clean fresh meat how much you want to
bet I can't wait to ask you how you feel
like 15-20 minutes A lot of people I
feel like I just got adrenaline so I'm
gonna feel pretty good just because I'm
already my heart's gone my mind is
running a mile a minute this by the way
I know we usually don't get too
explicitor but that is a massive
testicle yeah that's huge so what animal
is that from man because that is uh is
that larger than average these are
actually all um human organs oh well you
know that Kudos on that guy man you
should to be proud yeah these are all
bull uh this is from from Cal but go
ahead and just take
I'm gonna help you out here Graham
here this is across I'll give this to
you first and then I'm gonna make make a
serving for this like I said I can't I
can't oh because the bone well don't
there's no bone yeah there's no bone on
it yeah there's no bone you're all the
way there man you're gonna be proud of
yourself tomorrow
it's liver and bone marrow you know this
is the food our original human food that
allowed our craniums to explode because
what they are today brain and bone
marrow because uh before we were apex
predators we were scavengers and we
couldn't access the carcass but we could
take these skeletal remains back we
could take these bones back the cranium
and the femur bones and we learn how to
crack these open with percussion
technology and these are the foods that
we evolved with to become the baddest
mammalian Predators Graham
you know it's so funny it would make fun
of my grandparents for not eating sushi
and they'd be like no it's raw fish and
be like no that's so good I feel like
it's the same thing on that cheers
everyone I don't know if I can do the
whole thing in there
oh
the consistency is tough right
but what about the day so this is fine
it's it for me it's the mental and the
texture
tasty taste doesn't that one was uh that
honestly that one was the toughest for
me really
um it's a little too chalky for me and
this is this is what's Wild oh it's on
my teeth yeah me too if you get this out
of the cow it's already about 9 800
Degrees it's succulent have you ever
you've had it at like a steak restaurant
or something right bone marrow um yeah I
have actually yeah yeah and that
richness is how it comes out of the cow
like that once you cool it by about five
to ten degrees it hardens up it becomes
waxy
like this yeah but that that's it I'm so
glad you know what what I could do Alex
to keep you there gotta wash it down you
wanna I could put this on this little
plate Alex you want that yeah that's
what that is the point does your camera
work yeah that's why I gave you the
plate it makes you feel like strength it
makes you feel like courage it makes you
feel like honor
that's right it makes you feel all these
virile like qualities
because because this is what we evolved
with like I said when we became the
baddest mammalian predators that ever
lived this is what we ate and we
recently have taken this away from our
diet we still need this to express our
highest and most dominant form there's
exclusive peptides in each respective
organ a liver is called a liver because
there's only peptides and signaling
molecules and nourishment and a liver
that you can get from a liver that same
story goes for every other organ right
so I mean for someone who says hey you
can eat steak and get the same kind of
nourishment there's no way I'm not gonna
miss the opportunity to post a be real
before we get into this
um I do have a really good question for
for liver king
um and liver King I just want to let you
know this question is brought to you by
my sponsor Lexar over here yeah Grace
you're asking if he uses Lexar memory
cards great company I got I got one
right here what are you talking about
um so there's been a lot of uh like you
were saying that people are saying oh do
you really eat this stuff I I you know
you made a joke that you got AB implants
and then people were going off that you
know if you have ab and plants
um and I fell into the rabbit hole of
watching all these videos and some guy
on YouTube he had a lot of a lot of
followers he said you did not have AB
implants but he was like he was like
thoroughly convinced that you had AB
etching yeah can you confirm or deny
that right here and set the record
straight well I'm gonna set the record
straight like I shared before uh in 2018
I went to Singapore I was the first
human to ever have this done I had Gene
editing done right I had my myostatin
Gene uh modified and so doing that
allows you to express these uh these
physical attributes that I have today so
to set the record straight you know any
and all of these accusations you know
like I like to have fun with them right
I don't know what abetching is but I
know who said this stuff
um he's such a smart guy I mean he's so
articulate and he's so smart that this
is the deal he he could say that you had
anything done and he can say it in such
a way that so convincing because of how
smart he is guys
I I don't shave I don't comb my hair I
don't I don't take a shower the only
place I use soap would be my growing and
you don't take a shower if anything I
might here's the thing I don't take a
traditional shower I I don't use soap I
don't use chip like this hair's never
been washed the beer has never been
washed there's never been soap on my
chest right we have well water we have a
lake we jump in the lake we we get into
a cold plunge but um I don't pick out an
outfit right I mean every single day
when I get out of my wooden playing bed
I don't have to turn the lights on and
go like that I put whatever shorts are
on top right my closet is just full of
shorts I mean do you really think this
guy and by the way the only reason why I
dressed up today it's because of you
guys you dressed up I'm wearing my fan
my fanciest stuff there's a story to
this which I hope that we'll get more
into but I'm wearing my fanciest watches
yeah I noticed the one that's a good one
yeah my fanciest necklace right I know
where that necklace you know where it
came from yep it came from the last time
I was here yep and here's my goal as a a
little preview to hopefully what's gonna
happen
um I hope to be able to pay it forward
and hope to be able to give the necklace
away today on this podcast no so so so
my my answer back to you it's like
when you're really a primal when you
express your truth in most authentic
form when you do this because people are
really hurting when there's other kids
like your kids that need this kind of
nourishment that need this message right
because you know how many kids are out
there taking ADHD medications when all
they have is a nutrient deficiency if
you go to amazon.com and and you look at
ancestral supplements livers you're
going to see you're going to see tens
and thousands of reviews of anecdotes
that talk about these things
specifically and so I got to do my job
right and how do I do my job how do I
express you know my most here's the
thing like I just got to be me nobody
can be me the way that I can be me
nobody could be grammed the way Graham
can be gram nobody could be jacked the
way Jack could be jacked same for you
Alex so it's like you know what if I can
just wake up and if I can be that
version of me you see this guy is going
to get an AB etching you know you think
I'm gonna go get liposuction now it
seems like you're always shirtless how
do you walk into like a business how do
you go out to a restaurant how do you
you see a lot of places no shirt no
shoes no service does this Supply lie to
you I'm the liver King right and that's
what I say I mean I I go to uh Joe
Rogan's comedy and by the way I think
Joe Rogan is an absolute Legend right
quick tangent oh he's like four people I
hold in the highest regard right first
is George Washington then we have Chuck
Norris we have Rocky Balboa and we have
Joe Rogan right these are like my four
like most favorite badass primals right
in the world so I go to uh Joe Rogan's
comedy here in Las Vegas the last time
we're here and um hey you got to put a
shirt on I go hey I'm liver King I never
got permission
and uh like okay I mean you you know as
long as you're you half the time this is
it right if you can lead with that kind
of confidence you know they let me in I
sit through the whole show what about
other businesses like you're walking
dead you know like at a restaurant let's
just said you go to restaurants so
here's the thing um I love the life that
I've created I hardly ever leave it
right I have
um liver King lake house which is about
20 acres of wooded area on the lake
that's where I spend most of my time we
have liver King Ranch just about 45
minutes north we have liver King beach
house just 45 actually about an hour and
a half South like and I have liver King
Chef Lionel like why would you leave I
have all the food that I need there
right it's not like I go buy clothes I
mean let me ask you this why why do you
go to a business well to a restaurant I
like the experience and and so what like
what is that like what do you mean the
experience what does that mean ah the
food getting out of the house uh just I
would say a combination of both of those
just find something new new experience
yeah trying new place I was just talking
to somebody about that on the car
novelty in and of itself sure is an
adventure right and and so for me I got
a job to do do when it's dinner time
this is my most important meeting of the
day like I call this my board meeting
this is my my time to be an exclusive
and dedicated dad so I got an agenda for
dinner right and if I have Liberty I
have liver King Chef Lionel I got my
family right here I have no other
outside distractions and so here's the
thing I don't leave I'm just getting to
your point I don't leave my house
because I absolutely love the life I've
created there my kids are self-taught at
home I work from home right and if I
come if I travel my kids come with me so
I don't I don't go buy shirts I don't go
get you know ex experiences like that I
mean we're here now right and um and we
are going to do a dinner we're doing a
private dinner so we got a private room
doing a private dinner with some badass
guests and I'm not wearing a shirt right
and it's and so like that's sort of the
deal and if somebody says hey man you
got to wear a shirt like listen I'm not
wearing a shirt I'm just not gonna do it
but wouldn't it be easy though just to
put on a shirt
what if you told me right now hey man
just put on a shirt just do it just do
it I'll give you a shirt we have a shirt
we have an extra one and I would just
rip through it
but here's the deal this is really
important to me because
um how we look and how we speak that's
why language is so important right how
we look and how we speak is a true
authentic expression a pure expression
of who we really are right you show me
somebody bare-chested you give me 10
minutes of conversation with them let me
assess how developed their ideas how or
how organized their philosophy their
principles are right and I'll tell you
if I want that man in my tribe if the
Zombie Apocalypse Now does this mean
everything of course it doesn't of
course there's exceptions to that but
but we can make split judgments right I
believe how you doing things how you do
everything again not always the case but
I'm not surprised when somebody like
Alex ormozzi shows up jacked out of his
mind smart as [ __ ] right and then with
the sort of philosophies that he has I'm
not surprised this doesn't surprise me I
see stuff like this all the time I see
the reciprocal of that too when somebody
walks away walks around completely out
of shape and then they go to their car
and their car looks horrific and and
sometimes just for fun I look inside the
car you know what you see inside the car
oh I know fast food Rappers that's my
guess it's fast food rappers it's drinks
it's like a garage there's a whole
garage and then you ask and it blows my
mind we had somebody who interviewed for
a supply chain position you know I
looked at the car bumper stickers
everywhere just a total mess inside I'm
like supply chain very structured
analytical you know higher level problem
solving
okay I'll still give you the benefit of
the doubt we started talking this hey
man just grab your house for me the
inside of your house let's grab every
room as he started to describe it he
actually did a decent job describing it
but he described what a mess it is right
and then I could see that the mind was a
little messy too and so I think it's
just really important for me because of
the job that I need to do right because
there's this lady Cindy who came up to
me at Jeep week her husband tried to
start a fight with me and and he goes
hey no no but hey lover didn't work for
me I bought your supplements they suck
but uh but my wife hasn't left the house
in two years has chronic fatigue
fibromyalgia hasn't left the house in
two years started taking the supplements
that I think suck and now she's here at
Jeep week connecting with the outside
world right because of stories like this
because of people that experience
infertility that can now conceive and
bring a child into the world I'm like I
got to do my job so how do I do my job
how do I how do I convincingly do my job
with my brand to express my value to the
outside world right before social media
I didn't wear a shirt before social
media I had the beer and so now am I
going to go on social media and I'm
going to change that version of me right
because like I said the way that you
speak the way that you look I believe is
an outward expression of what you
believe and I think you know more about
me than I know about you when we first
meet one another right so that's a big
part with a shirt when it comes to
businesses I don't go places I like I
said I love the fact that I live and
what we're staying right now we're
staying at the Four Seasons I walked in
you know and um maybe it doesn't hurt to
have the pit how sweet but I walked in
they walked me up to the penthouse suite
have you guys been over there to the
penthouse suite never it's like probably
three or 3 500 square feet it's
beautiful it's expansive it's abundant
it gives you room to express your
highest most dominant form they open up
the doors they give you they roll out
the carpet I'm not wearing a shirt you
know and so um that's a big deal to me
you know but then where do you sleep too
I've I've heard you if you sleep on the
floor we sleep on the floor yeah yeah we
sleep on the floor and in an EMF tank
tent tent as well really traveling
because our back home our room is really
is already shielded you know but this is
a real big deal to me you know like
um I talk to a lot of individuals
they're like hey man how do I get a you
know ahead in life I'm like hey tell me
about your day really tell me about your
day how do you start it and they start
telling me about no no no no no no let's
go from being in bed how do you wake up
what do you do do you push the snooze
button most people hit the snooze button
do either you guys you hit the snooze
button sometimes well a lot of people
surprisingly hit the snooze button three
or four times they can't even get out of
bed that bed is so comfortable listen
I'll tell you where I sleep it's not
that comfortable
listen I wake up I can't wait to get out
of bed because it's like okay the ground
is not that comfortable and I can't wait
to fight for what I have going on so
there's a big thing related to where you
sleep most people are sleeping on EMF or
I'm sorry uh um they're sleeping on
off-gassing mattresses right you're
breathing in off-gassing non-native
materials increasing your estrogen we
don't even know how it wrecks havoc in
other areas right you have metal Springs
that are conducting ambient electricity
right you're supposed to be in a deep
parasympathetic state to get your best
rest in recovery you can't do that you
know and then and then you're on this
cast that's like you notice when you get
in your bed it's just a perfect height
and then when you get out it's like the
perfect height right when you go visit
with these modern day print of culture
tribes you got people in their 80s and
90s that are getting all the way down
without their hands they get all the way
up without their hands right if you've
used that Mobility that kind of Mobility
for all your life you never stop using
it you never lose it and I don't know if
you've seen any of the studies on
longevity but this is one of the
predictors of longevity can you get up
and down off the ground without using
your hands right so there's a whole host
of things related to this but for me
again it comes down to First principle
thinking and how to modern day print of
culture tribes live you don't see beds
Like That You Don't See beds with metal
Springs you don't see beds with
off-gassing non-native materials most
people it's a bed on the ground a little
bit of dirt maybe a little bit of plant
matter this is where they sleep they
continue to use that kind of Mobility
every single day we've outsourced
discomfort and now we have things like
that so I think that is part of the
problem but I wouldn't tell people hey
that that's why you should do it I think
it's a big deal for everybody but man
especially kids I'm like they deserve a
better shot then why wouldn't you create
a bed that's not off gas and it's maybe
built from these materials that you
could sell I love that you brought that
up yeah so right now I have a handful of
companies we got four or five more we
got five more that we're just launching
this year that'll be launched by the end
of the year and what I'm really focusing
on what I really focus on is liver King
right what I focus on is making sure
that this message goes mainstream that's
the most important thing to me so I have
a CEO of tip of the spear so if you go
to tip of the spear dot Co you're going
to find the companies that we have that
are currently in the water and you're
going to find companies that are coming
soon we're building 100 companies across
every category right so um so to answer
your question this is going to happen
okay it's going to be a while before
that happens but most of my focus really
is like we're going to go create content
and we're gonna go spread this message
far and wide so that people will know
about ancestral living in these nine
ancestral tenants sure speaking of that
oh I was about to say we should have
Alex I just want to say it's been about
what 15 20 minutes since we ate that I
feel like amped do you feel like I think
it's scary I could be a bit of a placebo
effect personally because I feel like I
was all amped up from like the getting
over the mental hurdle of eating it
really yeah I feel like I just drank
like a one or two cups yeah more well I
was I was I was all I will gladly I was
eating a long time does it this go bad
at some point or is this it's good right
now but but here's the deal um give
somebody some liver pills
so some desiccated raw liver pills by
ancestral supplements okay and and don't
tell them what it is say hey I'm gonna
tell you what it is later and see how
they feel in 15-20 minutes don't tell
them what it is yeah you know what does
that do yeah um you know a lot of people
will ask me hey what's in it oh there we
go oh wow we got some ancestral
supplements together okay is this good
to take right now this guy's ready this
guy's good to go and it's certain size
is six capsules six capsules equals one
ounce of raw liver so what does this do
yeah so what does it do um you know
there's a whole lot of this nourishment
that you're missing that you're just not
getting right and so the the most
important thing that you need to know
about this is again we evolved with this
stuff since the beginning beginning of
time we still need this to express our
highest most dominant form so what this
is going to give you is it's going to
give you choline it's going to give you
riboflavin it's going to give you real
bioavailable vitamin B12 it's going to
get you vitamin A which you probably
don't get you might think I get it from
beta carotene but the carotenoids is a
whole nother issue try to convert that
to legitimate vitamin A which is retinol
which is bioavailable there's a whole
bunch of stuff in here that you're
record that you need to express your
highest it's going to give you energy
Drive determinate again this is why I
talk about my name is liver King because
liver is King you start eating this
eighty percent of people feel it right
and if you feel it and it gives you more
energy and more drive and more
determination again to take Massive
Action and kick ass in life like this is
what everything is predicated from right
if you start here you're going to say oh
my God maybe this guy's not such an
idiot maybe I should listen to some of
these other nine ancestral tenants so I
mean how much how much am I supposed to
take of this it's just yeah serving six
capsules am I supposed to take six a day
or what's what's the strategy behind
this the strategy probably should be to
talk to a product expert
um because uh sure but because normally
people start with one or two okay and
and again one or two a day okay um and
then if you feel great kicking ass on
one or two a day started one keep it at
one or two a day all right um if if you
want to see what would happen if you
level up and go to three or four or five
or six a lot of people really do need
six a day to feel their best that's what
you take
um well the the thing is I eat a pound
of liver a day
so I eat a powder liver a day when I'm
traveling or on vacation I don't go
anywhere without my ancestral
supplements right or the equivalent of
all right I don't have one you know that
one yeah okay
a pound of liver oh look we got another
present oh wow we got another present so
here's the deal okay
for a lot of people they're not gonna
eat what we all you would do it right
but Graham this is tough this is tough
for me what is it what is this I saw you
making this out there by the way what's
up my major is Boneless by the way bonus
boneless yeah it's like a bonus
so I'll tell you what actually this
smells good this is called whole Feast
it has liver heart pancreas spleen
kidneys bone blood and colostrum and it
and um and so here's the thing again
you're you're fine eating this but maybe
at some point near the sign
maybe at some point you're going to say
Hey listen I don't want to Source it or
I'm out of it or or Graham how much you
want to bet there's so many people like
you yeah that know that you need the
nourishment but you're not gonna do the
things to get the nourishment right so
there's this protein shake it's called
the whole Feast it has all this stuff in
it let's do it cheers and let's give it
a shot see Jimmy don't tell me what's in
it until uh until I have it no no let's
say I've done it cheers milk chocolate
hey that tastes great Does that taste
good yeah that tastes like um just like
my options nutrition yeah I think better
than Optimum Nutrition because it's like
thicker I like it more what did you mix
this with well there's um
like water oh I don't know um liver King
Chef Lionel oh wait
wow see this tastes like uh Optimum
Nutrition mixed with milk which is like
a higher standard than water it tastes
like actually well if you think about it
there's colostrum in here which is
Mother's first milk right and so um
colostrum is such a power this is why we
tried to get this stuff in here because
you need more than just liver and most
people push this stuff away and you've
got to get this nourishment in your life
so we also try to make it easy for
people you know at the end of the day
what I tell everybody is the best thing
you can do is go on a hunt go get that
kind of connection with Landon listen if
you're not going to do that go to your
butcher you know how many people are not
going to do that most people won't do it
right so go to your grocery store or go
to an online like farmers market or
Rancher like we got white oak pasture we
got Piedmont teas you can effortlessly
order this stuff but most people still
won't do it right and so that's sort of
like what what a lot of my businesses
are predicated on is if you want
something convenient that you don't have
to taste or let's say you do want to
taste it the whole Feast is going to
give you all this nourishment ancestral
supplements are going to give you this
kind of nourishment because one way or
another you got to get in in your diet
you know the hierarchy the best way to
get it but if you're not going to do
that
I know you got 20 cent coffee but you
know how much money people pay for
coffee right it's like I mean guys for
just a little over a dollar a day you
can get this nourishment back in your
life yeah this is good I I approve of
that good if I could drink that that's
great all right yeah I agree and also I
you know I think we should uh what are
you trying to do Graham I want you to
eat the stuff that we ate all right all
right oh he hasn't done that yet no uh
okay
what do I eat first I dropped that I
can't see over there but hold on so I
have all these oh you probably can't see
I would just say start shoveling man
yeah okay shovel and just hold it up to
the camera I just don't know what this
is I'll tell you what it is after
okay you want to know before or after
I'll just eat it
I don't like the texture of that one
I think it's the same thing maybe No I
gave you different of everything okay
well it looks very different the same
yep
doing better than I did man you're
killing it I know what that one was
based off the reaction yeah
that one was a little strong
and then I got this one this one's a
little bit lighter in color surprised
you're doing this well Alex yeah to be
honest yeah
I don't like
oh I don't like your texture of that one
yeah
I don't like the texture of that all
right and then
yeah I really don't like that it's
getting worse
it's like hot ones uh and then I got
this this guy right here uh uh it's so
hard to tell sorry guys
um it is hard to tell but you crushed it
oh that one I think it's hard because
that one feels very muscly and the only
thing that I know that that's muscle is
like I've never had heart but based off
of like the muscle I think that's art
and then you got this one that's just
kind of slimy looking
I like that one
so the one you really didn't like the
slimy one no that one's the worst oh
okay got it yeah I'll do I'll do is this
bone marrow yeah now I've never had bone
marrow not even at a restaurant because
I've been too much of a wimp to try it
so
so that that one's a weird one for me
the texture yeah um the textures so is
that meat I what it what is that
yeah that's predominantly fat ah yeah
it's almost all fat and it's uh
saturated fat which is why you get that
waxy consistency but it's like a natural
saturated yeah that's right let me ask
you a question liver King so I recently
had a lifestyle change completely
um maybe about two and a half months ago
Jack came over to my house I'm trying to
lose weight
and and um he came over to my house we
threw away everything my wife had to get
on board
to get rid of everything
so now
I'm only buying
um like Whole Foods I don't know how to
explain it like like I'll buy meat
I'll buy vegetables I'll buy fruit
and um I'm glad to say I'm down almost
30 pounds oh yeah but uh what can what
what advice would you give me as
somebody who's who's trying to
you know just live a healthier happier
life and is obviously a little bit
overweight here trying to trying to what
what advice would you give me that would
make the biggest difference yeah you
know what's Wild is that um
a lot of people that want to live better
and feel better they think it's really
focused on like movement and diet and
and it's all non-incestial tenants it
really is
um and the same thing goes in business
right you want to be better in business
I'm going to tell you I'm going to give
you the same advice that I'm about to
give you right now what happens if you
don't sleep good for three or four days
what do you think happens uh my guess is
you probably get tired
here's what's gonna happen you're gonna
feel like [ __ ]
your energy is going to be like [ __ ]
your hormones are going to be in the
basement your neurochemistry is going to
be off you're going to have hardly any
Drive determination right I'm just kind
of giving you an extreme example to
emphasize how important sleep is and and
most people you might think that you're
sleeping well because you're in bed for
eight hours or six hours or whatever but
if you don't get early morning sun
Through The Eyes on the face on the skin
to set your bio circadian rhythm so your
body really knows when to be an awakened
alert versus sleepy and sleeping if you
don't do that first thing in the morning
you're not sleeping optimally if you
don't finish your last meal three to
four hours before bed you're not
sleeping optimally if you don't take in
the sunset as a final environmental cue
that the day is winding down and then
blocks of the blue light blocking
glasses so your brain's not confused
whether it's day or night you're not
sleeping optimally right we don't have
to get into the bed in the F's and these
types of things but sleep is so
critically important it's perhaps the
biggest lever I always start with liver
because liver it's easy to be compliant
you can start with this but to do these
things to sleep better can be a little
challenging
um so it's really all nine ancestral
tenants it's how you sleep eat move
Shield connect cold Sun fight Bond they
all play a role in how we look feel and
function they all Express something
epigenetically right so a lot of people
are focused on um how they eat right and
you've made some Lifestyle Changes how
you eat how you're moving and you're
going to continue to make progress but
if you improve your sleep if you improve
the way that you bond with people if you
Shield a little bit better if you get
sun if you connect your bare feet to the
ground right we're able to express a
higher more dominant form our physiology
and biochemistry will do what it's
designed to do so what I would encourage
you to do is what you're doing right now
right I mean if this is working keep
doing what you're doing right now but I
would really encourage you to look at
all nine ancestral tenants because if
you look at all nine ancestral tenants
and you can make some progress you're
going to see it's a whole lot easier to
do with what your goal is and you're
probably not going to hit a plateau what
would you say your business is now you
say liver King but what is what is liver
King as a business yeah liver King as a
business is really the CEO of the
ancestral lifestyle it's the model teach
and preach this way so that the message
goes mainstream how are we going to do
that right I've told you why we're doing
it right how we're doing it is we're
getting as many views we're getting as
many Impressions right we're getting it
out there as much as we can so from the
time I wake up I'm creating content
right I mean within 30 seconds of waking
up I'm creating content right stack the
sun in the Earth get the Sun and you do
the outside get your bare feet connected
to the ground boom there's a video right
and and then I'm getting into the gym
and I'm showing people hey you got to
move every day too lift heavy things and
so the the deal right now is we're going
to keep creating content right we share
some liver King philosophy we share
ideas that are all around these nine
ancestral tenants and then sometimes
we're just having a little fun right and
then ancestral tenant is whatever I want
it to be so normally I'm like hey today
we're doing ancestral tenant 10 which is
having a little fun so right right now
this is the goal is um I don't even run
books for for liver King and I'm just
like all we're focused on right now is
getting this message out there is going
mainstream with this mess message
creating opportunities again to model
teaching you're getting the bone marrow
out of your mouth still aren't you found
it and it just I could tell look on your
face
um but but this is the thing you know
and and you know what's Wild is um
people are really responding to it right
I always say that people pay for value
with time money or both right and as
evidenced by the viewership the primals
going from zero to six million in a year
you know it's it's I mean how did we do
it I mean a lot of people ask hey how'd
you do it right I'm like you know what I
could tell you it's because I got the a
world-class social media company which I
do right they're worth every single
penny they're expensive they're world
class right and and this is all
everything I'm saying is true I do I can
tell you because Joe Rogan helped launch
me from obscurity into the mainstream he
he's talked about me a couple of times
and I couldn't be more grateful right
all that's true we made a couple of
really cool viral videos of eating the
entire testicle that went viral I had 51
shots of eggs that was under two minutes
the last one had the shell on Barstool
Sports put that on I mean there's been
so many incredible opportunities that
have helped me but at the end of the day
like I said people pay for value and so
I think the value is right how do we
express our value right we can express
it physically social emotionally how to
connect with each other how to connect
with the audience mentally
intellectually like how are we
expressing these ideas right how do we
express ourselves uh from a spiritual
standpoint you know we talk about these
things sometimes not not necessarily
that um even that we have souls that we
are souls right we talk about all not
living in non-living things being
interconnected right these aren't just
my ideas like these are early ancestral
ideas we talk about all these things to
try and advance that kind of value so
that we can spread the nine ancestral
tenants far and wide this is what I'm
focused on doing right now all right we
don't run books for these businesses I
do have a CEO for all my other
businesses right we have a centralized
CFO and and so coming on this trip
since we're not running books we know
that we're in the red so it's like okay
who's going to pay for this trip
so and we're hoping ancestral
supplements pays for this trip right if
I can promote ancestral self because
whenever I travel I always take some
supplements with me yeah and one of my
companies is called the fittest a lot of
times I'll bring those supplements king
or honor yeah so is it primarily then
it's it's a social media business with
you as the face and then the products
are what would pay for more of the more
of the message to get out there is that
is that the case I wouldn't say that
yeah okay I mean really I would say
irrespective because I've never done
that before okay I've never brought
these products really yeah I mean are we
the first you're the first yes we have
uh Logan Paul and Company had a whole
Feast back in the day so we've done some
whole fee stuff
um but but in my mind I've never been
like hey let's have somebody because all
I've been focused on is how do we spread
this message you know once again I don't
actually don't know if I said these
statistics but 80 of the populationless
paycheck to paycheck struggles page do
you guys probably know that don't you
right and why do we struggle like that
right because we're ex we're attempting
to express status our worth and
potential with things that we can buy
today at the mall we're trying to this
is how valuable I am check me out look
at what I'm wearing look at what I'm
driving and guess what you put on a
credit card you don't even own it right
80 of us are struggling we're living
beyond our means 70 of us are overweight
half or obese 50 of us are on
prescription medicines 40 have or will
get cancer man this is wild this is wild
20 of kids This Tall around prescription
medicine so this is all I care about and
I've told you my why right you know what
I come from so I don't care what it's
costing but this is what we're gonna do
if we can mitigate some of that cost hey
that's cool too and I know that you guys
know the difference of being a mercenary
versus a missionary right if you're a
real missionary if you're public about
your wire in the world and then if you
only hire True Believers that believe
what you believe because they've
struggled with the same things right
intractable Crohn's they were done with
their life severe and tractable
depression recalcitrant issues that
nobody could ever fix they abandoned the
mo the modern world ways they started
doing some of this ancestral living
stuff they got a new lease on life this
is a True Believer right when you get
True Believers like that in your
companies now customer comes to you and
this happens every single day several
times a day customers come in with the
same issues that our True Believers have
and nobody can connect and love and
listen like these guys I don't know if
you've ever heard anybody that that has
had chronic pain and fibromyalgia but
they've complained to all the friends
and family they don't want to hear it
anymore doctors don't want they've been
to five doctors they don't want to hear
it anymore right nobody wants to listen
my people know that they've been through
that so the first thing we do is we book
and it would love we listen to them hey
we've had the same thing I know how you
feel we have so many other customers
that have gone through the same thing
you should be inspired There's Hope here
what you need to do is go get some sun
take off your shoes go connect and I'm
gonna follow up with you in seven to ten
days you got all the reason to be
hopeful right and this is this is what
we do right and so I always say this is
this is what our Core Business is our
sustainable con competitive Advantage is
that we care more and we care deeper
than anybody and if you can get that be
public with your wire in the world only
hire True Believers they're going to go
to the edge of the Earth for you and
then that value people are going to feel
that value and then they're going to
want to reciprocate that value right and
we say hey go go get your liver and bone
marrow go get your heart go get your
what it depends on what you where you
need targeted support right
um go do that if you're not going to do
that we got a simple convenient solution
for you too so I just want you to know
from a liver King standpoint this is
where I spend most of my time right I
also own about seven or eight companies
I own almost all of them 100 yeah what
are the companies so right now I have
ancestral supplements I have heart and
soil the fittest Medicine Man uh Plant
company I have a company called
Birthright there's a excuse me there's a
few other that we're launching
um and and I I consider liver King a
company yeah no we got a CEO we got a
team um I think most of them how big is
the team I was I was surprised everyone
came in I'm like okay this is a big team
and then I this you show up and like
it's a bigger team it's uh it's uh like
like a classroom basically you bring
everybody it's like I'm I was blown away
is this is this your entire team or is
it some some of the team you know what
we have uh probably
most are from liver King company and
then we have a couple people with our
social media company once again I just
want to plug them they're the best in
the world sure um I want to give credit
to all these guys because there is no
way in hell that I did this yeah you
know again I got the why and I know how
to hire right I know how to build teams
and and I've always said like in life
you get what you tolerated you get what
you demand and I demand Excellence of
myself so I demand Excellence of all
these guys here and I pull them all
forward you know but but here's the deal
they pulled me forward so basically you
see all these problems in the world and
you want to try to solve them using the
tenants that you have and one way you
can get people to obey the tenants is by
your different businesses such as the
supplements such as spreading the
message through liver King uh which also
is I'm sure a great marketer towards all
these other businesses that you also
have it's the rising tide lifts all
boats right right and that's basically
the the whole summary of the entire
liver King brand and motivation and goal
yeah I think so I'm curious how all your
businesses were doing before for liver
King and then once at liver King as far
as like the social media presence and
then with liver King growing how that
has affected all of your businesses you
know it's wild hardly at all
hardly at all and and because I've just
launched liver King a year ago here's
the thing liver King existed a long way
before a year ago right I never wanted
to go on social media I never wanted to
do a podcast I never wanted to be like
public liver King I love my life I don't
know if you've heard me say this before
but before liver King on social media I
was rich and Anonymous it's a pretty
badass Life to Live go anywhere
do anything no one's going to distract
you now if I get on the lake on the boat
boats are coming up hey liver King liver
King I mean we're trying to leave the
Four Seasons hey lever King can you know
and this is why part of the team is so
big you know because I got bodyguards
and the bodyguards aren't to protect me
it's to protect people that got out of
line because God forbid maybe I'm a dude
you know somebody else are huge those
are the two guys one of them's like
seven feet tall yeah oh my gosh I
thought for a second like maybe Shaq
just came in yeah I literally thought
the same thing I thought it was Shaq I
was like what is [ __ ] because yeah
because our doors are like eight feet
and it seemed like he was almost had to
like get underneath the door and I was
like I was incredible Shaq is that tall
but but in terms of how my other
businesses grow my other business my
other businesses grow 50 a year year
over year so what kind of impact have I
had on these businesses is really
marginal where do you invest where I
invest is like we're doing 100 of these
companies
and you know why because people are
hurting and they hate their lives right
they're suffering and struggling with
such depth that they need to hear this
message I need to meet them where
they're at in their respective category
people have chronic and recurrent Decay
they have no idea why so I'm launching a
dental company to meet you where you're
at to help give you this kind of
nourishment you know if you have oral
health issues you know how many other
issues that you have that you don't even
know about
because you have nutrient deficiencies
why you have oral health issues in the
first place you got issues with your
product plan so what I need to do is I
need to meet people where they're at in
a hundred different categories so any
extra money that I get I can use a cash
flow to to I can use cash flow to launch
these businesses it's not expensive to
launch these businesses right and so
what we're if you ask where I'm
investing it's really like it's not
really where I'm investing like my money
this is really right that's my time got
it my effort like my will to succeed got
it walk us through a day in the life of
the liver King how do you wake up to the
the moment you end your day what's it
look like you know I alluded to this
earlier so I'm going to answer the
question but you know like I said a lot
of people can't get out of bed in the
morning and then when they finally get
out of bed they take a [ __ ] shower shave
pick out an outfit they've done yoga
meditation Journal right and now they're
sipping their bone broth and half the
day is gone like guys come on like if
you want to get ahead of life if you
want more in life you got to do more in
life so I get out of my wooden plank bed
right and I go right out to the patio I
connect with the Sun and the Earth I've
made my first piece of content it's been
30 seconds and then I go right into the
gym immediately after that I do the
hardest thing I'm going to do all day to
make a few more pieces of content doing
that and so the hardest thing I'm going
to do all day is gone it's still early
morning most people still getting out of
their bed so immediately after that I
meet with one of the companies of a CEO
of one it's it's basically CEO meeting
hour and so I call it CEO meeting hour
because I have quite a few CEOs we have
an estate manager I call them the CEO of
our lifestyle of our household we have
liver King Ranch CEO right so we meet
with CEOs of our respective businesses
for about two or three hours after that
what I do is uh I get back into the gym
for my second workout of the day so
spend another hour or so in the gym
right after doing that work out in the
gym gym I get back on getting ready for
a podcast or getting on a podcast doing
a podcast studying for a podcast trying
to develop my ideas
um after that I like I told you guys
earlier I think I do my most important
meeting of the day with my board meeting
it's my my one job I gotta do
as a dad is to firm my kids with a depth
of challenge worth and potential so that
one day they come to believe in
themselves so I got this one hour to do
that with them I see them in the house
all throughout the day right again I
think what we model is so much more
important than what we teach and preach
so my kids get to see that all day long
they see me you know a figuratively give
people hugs you know a CEO comes in I'm
like okay connect me back to your why
why are you here connect me to a
customers why let's start there talk to
me about the culture the chemistry how
are things going you got two or three
things that we can talk about hey how
can I support you all right we're gonna
do it again next week you know my kids
get to see that kind of stuff right so I
do this meeting with my kids and one of
the biggest things we do during that
meeting is we have them do liver King
philosophy and there's different LK
philosophy every day I always tell them
it's not what you say it's how you say
it and people rarely remember
what you said but they'll always
remember how you made them feel so
they'll remember how you made them feel
usually based on how you said it so we
practiced them saying that and I love
the way that they can say things now
especially when there's an audience
around and then their friends practice
it and I'm like oh my God your friends
are horrific oh my my kids are really
good you know so we do that at dinner
and then after dinner I walk with liver
Queen hand in hand we take in the sunset
you know she normally has an agenda
because we're not hanging out all
throughout the day right so she she's
got this piece of paper and she's like
checking them off like we're going
through these things you know and so she
has that meeting with me and sometimes
she'll even tell me hey you said this
thing at dinner I don't agree like
here's where you went wrong did she take
notes of things like that like you you
didn't put the toilet seat down we gotta
talk about this oh that's funny you gave
me this look at this time I didn't know
it's much higher level than that yeah
yeah but uh but yeah she'll let me have
it like could you give us an example of
uh like what might be on that list uh
I'll give you an example um you know so
sorry it was turning 15 and I say
Striker this is your rite of passage
you're going to do Barbarian and uh she
knows I don't want to say it's probably
going to sound wrong maybe if in a lot
of people she lets me be the leader of
the house right and so she doesn't do a
lot of challenging in front of the kids
right we talk about that and then the
next day
I'm usually wrong and I say hey guys I
was wrong
lyrically and your mom she told me this
thing here's where I was wrong I
reserved the right to be wrong I don't
apologize for it I don't know if you
guys know but primitive culture tribes
don't even have a word for apologize
right there's no I'm sorry it's hey I'll
be better they recognize this is my
fault here's what went wrong I'll be
better this is what I try and uh um do
and so um
she doesn't want him to do much so we're
walking she goes hey I I don't think he
can do Barbarian I said why not she goes
I think it's going to hurt him like
permanently hurt him I said why she goes
because he weighs 120 pounds he's still
14 years old and you're gonna go make
him do this adult workout like this is
the whole point of it I don't know if
you guys know what Barbarian is but it's
a 70 pound backpack you got 70 pound
kettlebells in each hand you got 120
pounds on top of a sled that already
weighs 45 pounds so it's about 165
pounds on a sled and you got 20 pound
ankle weights and it's for one mile
right and so
um to have a young guy do that I knew
this would be the hardest thing he's
ever done and it's so much more than
physical right this is every part of you
right it's it's almost like again
um your physical is gone like you you
can't even make a face anymore you don't
even care you're slobbering doing this
you can barely breathe you know
everything it's there's something else
that happens right now when people turn
16 do you know how they celebrate it
sweet 16.
what is wrong with us right I mean every
primitive culture they have a legitimate
rite of passage to cross this Chasm
right so now they understand the worth
value and potential it's legitimate it's
real it's such a severe struggle that
they've overcome and persevered and they
fought through that now they know
something about themselves right
pregnant culture tribes do this or early
ancestors did this as well there's I
don't know if you guys know but the
Spartans would send their young away at
seven to a state-sponsored program until
they were 20 20 years old right um the
matcha ganga they do a vision quest for
three months right every primitive quote
the Aztec required um at 12 or 13 years
old you bring back a captive a
neighboring tribe for sacrifice right
it's wild you know the Messiah go on a
lion hunt at 13. we have
um sweet 16 party there's no real and
this is part of the reason why what I
think we have I think we have a soft
manicured man problem today and and
because it takes strength it really
takes Hard Times To Know strength and we
no longer require hard times because
everything can be easy today almost
everything is easy today if you're hot
which I'm hot we turn down the
thermostat right if you're cold you just
go inside you know like if you're
thirsty you have a drink it's like we we
comfort's not good for the organism but
we live with Comfort 24 7 today so this
is the deal I say hey you're going to do
this thing and she just can't believe it
like this is gonna hurt him this is
gonna [ __ ] him this is going to
disfigure him and I said I said he's no
matter what he's doing it no matter what
you say to me he's gonna do this don't
take this away from them him he needs to
do this and I need to see him do this
and she's like well what if he can't
like what do you mean what if he can't I
don't care how many days it takes to do
it you know I said what he needs to know
is it doesn't matter how many days it
takes what's going to happen is you're
going to sleep on the side you're going
to sleep in the trees I'll I'll bring
you a drink you know but you're going to
finish it and so here's the thing you
don't just wake up one day and do
Barbarian you train for him and so what
ends up happening is you do something
that nobody else thought you could do
you didn't think you could do it and
then you know what real strength is and
this is what I try and tell everybody
because advice I give to everyone's like
hey go learn the Barbarian first I say
start with lover right and then go learn
the Barbarian train the Barbarian become
a barbarian because once you know that
you'll know strength and it's not about
your ability to impose your force of
wealth physically you've crossed this
Chasm you figure out something that you
didn't think was possible and so now you
can replicate that process and point it
at anything as an entrepreneur as a
brother how do you train though for the
Barbarian well um there's a lot of
different ways you could start with 35
pound kettlebells right you could start
with just a backpack you could start
with Justice you can deconstruct and do
one Implement at a time or you could
have all implements at the same time
just have lighter weights and then load
up to it
um we would go on vacations a couple of
months before Striker's Barbarian and uh
Striker who brought his weights with him
he did the Barbarian no no no no but he
he didn't stop training okay he didn't
stop training and so when it was time
for him to do the Barbarian he crushed
the Barbarian how long did it take him a
couple of hours hmm yeah Mom's thinking
you know he's gonna be disfigured you
know and I remember I was going to a
meeting and uh I I said hey Rob you
check on your brother you know if he
needs something if he passes out you
know you call an ambulance and uh and
she goes hey I'm gonna go check on him I
said listen I gotta leave but you better
not because if he sees you see him
if if he sees his mom look at him that
way
he's done and so she she didn't go and
check on him and he killed it he kicked
ass right and again that confidence that
that gave him and immediately after that
we went and did a sacred heart it was
his first hunt together our first hunt
together and he takes an animal right he
gets that connection with the land with
the animal with me right what you're
capable of how you can provide for
yourself you you combine these forces
together for somebody who's not even 15
yet right to realize these types of
things you know when you look at
somebody who's been to these sorts of
depths you see it in their eyes you see
what they've been through right I always
say how can you scale and lead a company
if you can't scale and Lead yourself how
can you scale need a company if you're a
[ __ ] it's not an easy thing to do so go
learn the Barbarian train for the
Barbarian do the Barbarian be a
barbarian and renew that right of
passage frequently again once you know
that you know that you can point that
process at anything and everything at
any time especially I'm curious how
would this strategy be different if he
had a daughter I don't know I'd have
daughters I don't know yeah okay yeah
Graham we should do a barbarian
would you do it yeah I'd be open
you got me all hyped up I want to do a
Barbarian so bad right now you know it
sounds fun the greatest gift for you man
like I would love uh to have you guys
come to my neck of the woods and to do
I'd be easy no I mean tell us one man I
would go okay so to be continued we're
going to commit to each other we're
going to hold each other accountable
we're gonna hide the hide the hold this
in high honor right yeah each other
um but because uh you say it with such
Stoke which I love but I'm telling you
this will change you right this will so
so if you were to say hey you got some
advice for me to be an entrepreneur
right you've heard me say this five
times but it start with liver because
liver is King learn the Barbarian train
the Barbarian become a barbarian because
once you do that you're gonna know
strength it will change you forever
right um after that I said get really
clear on your why in the world again if
you know your why and it's altruistic
you're gonna be a missionary and people
will follow you you make that public and
then you can find True Believers you
have all their discretionary time when
you have a True Believer they'll go to
the edge of the Earth for you right you
don't have to micromanage anything right
these guys are going to come up with
ideas while they're on the [ __ ] when
they're driving they're not thinking
about other things because they've been
through the same thing they've been
through the depths of the struggle their
kids were born so underweight that they
thought they would lose their kids and
then their kids are robust and healthy
and kicking ass in life and they want
the same for other kids right that are
born the same way and then the last
thing I always say is take Massive
Action in a singular Direction without
pivoting because we see this all the
time right people select to do something
oh hey this other Market's cool let me
do some of this right you don't have to
Pivot when you know you're wiring the
world right when you know your why in
the world go in that direction and
within a couple years I guarantee you're
going to be a millionaire but what's way
more important than that again it's easy
to achieve it's easy all you gotta do is
work hard be focused right do the things
that are required to become a barbarian
and you will easily achieve but how much
you want to bet your life's gonna suck
most people I'm just saying that there's
a I bet you guys know a lot of them they
don't love their lives they might love
the things that they have they'll tell
you they love the things that they have
right but if you don't have someone to
share it with to really have this kind
of connection with if you don't have an
altruistic mission in life really to
connect with people to really help it's
like you know all value is not created
equal right I got 100 I got three
companies doing 100 million dollars is
that equal to three strip clubs doing
100 million dollars is it equal to three
soft drink companies doing 100 million
dollars is that kind of value equal
there's no way right one is helping The
Human Condition one is unraveling The
Human Condition so that's why I always
say I'm going to just repeat it start
with liver because liver is King learn
the Barbarian train the become the
Barbarian forthcoming right and then get
really clear on your why in the world
only hire True Believers and then take
Massive Action in a singular Direction
and you're going to achieve I got one
last question for you
what is your workout routine I well do
you do you have a set schedule
like what can I do to look like that
besides liver well this is the craziest
thing it's all nine ancestral tenants
what it all boils down to is hormone
optimization right if you sleep like
[ __ ] you're going to tank your hormones
your testosterone will be at 50 at where
it should be if you don't believe me go
sleep like take a baseline testosterone
and go sleep like [ __ ] for three days
and then how much you want to bet you
come to liver King house where
everything is perfect pristine sleep
conditions and where you thought your
testosterone was as average how much you
want to bet it goes up by 50 right if
you sleep like [ __ ] you're gonna tank
your testosterones if you eat like [ __ ]
which most people do unbeknownst to them
right they're they're consuming liquid
calories and Seed oils another processed
[ __ ] that's going to take your
testosterone if you move like [ __ ] which
most people are well you you've been
working out for how many days in a row
well I've been working out for 12 years
but I took a bit of time off in covid I
put on 15 pounds so I'm trying to lose
that 15 pounds by being dedicated to it
and um yeah do you lift heavy things I
do okay good yeah because you probably
know that's where it's at you know a lot
of people think that that they can
outrun a fat body yeah and and I'm like
oh my God there's so much I got to tell
you right our basal metabolic rate at
rest is when we burn 80 to 90 of our
calories and that's a turn by your lean
muscle mass so you got to be lifting
heavy things so if you lift heavy [ __ ]
you're going to optimize your hormones
right if you Shield like [ __ ] which is
the fourth tenant if you have your cell
phone next to your dick and balls this
is not good for your testosterone
where's your where's your phone
right right there
and if you don't believe me Explains It
Jack no mine's way over there across the
room yeah every cell phone company if
you read the packages or it's going to
tell you that there's ionizing radiation
that it heats up you shouldn't have it
next to your head right people have it
right here this is not okay right um and
this is not there's several tenants here
right and so once again I'm going to
make Shields really simple turn off your
Wi-Fi at night put your phone in
airplane mode don't put it right there
just do that you're going to be good
with Shield you're going to be way
further along than most people the fifth
ancestral tendon is connect right get
your Barefoot connected anchored
grounded into the Earth We're
electrophysical beings every single cell
in our body is electrical in nature and
what do cells do they signal to each
other to create tissue and then tissue
signals to express an organ and then
organs express our human being every
single cell is electrical nature the
Earth has a slightly negative charge
we've recently disconnected from the
earth we have Rebel sold shoes elevated
beds buildings cars right when's the
last time you had you you have your
shoes off right now so I could hope you
guys have a good answer when's the last
time you had your Barefoot connected to
the ground the Earth outside not inside
three hours ago oh yeah I can't stand it
I love it no I don't know why not I
don't like it I I always wear socks I
don't like my bare feet touching
anything especially anything outside so
just do this we're caught in socks you
need to get some cotton socks it has to
be native material if you have polyester
socks um this this is a substrate that
doesn't allow you to conduct with the
Earth connect with the Earth again this
costs nothing sure right and it only is
a small investment and every one of
these stacks and compounds right that's
a fifth ancestral tenant the sixth one
is thermal pressures we always evolved
with thermal pressures being really hot
and really cold we have heat shock
proteins we have cold shock proteins
right we have the reason why I'm hot
right now the reason why I'm sweating is
because I have such up regulated Brown
adipose tissue it's metabolically active
right I get into cold plunge that's 34
degrees for 10 to 15 minutes a week and
so I've up regulated this brand so it's
metabolically active I go through a bit
so without getting into too much of it
right we evolved with thermal pressures
we've recently taken this out of our
life to our detriment getting the sun
most people know about the sun right
most people know that it's going to give
us adequate vitamin D most people know
it's going to give us nitric oxide dump
most people know that we need that to
optimize our testosterone every single
one of the there's only two more
actually I'm just going to go through
them fight this is 8th and Central
tenant you guys already have this in
your lives right this is not like
physically fighting right this is having
a purpose a passion a promise an
altruistic goal in your life that you
can't wake up and Sprint towards because
you know the difference that you can
make right now if you got something like
that to fight for in contrast to
somebody who wakes up and is aimlessly
wondering about life right now if you
take the literal example when somebody
wins a fight after a UFC match right if
you take the Baseline testosterone you
win the fight you look at how much
higher that is versus the loser and how
much lower that is it's pretty massive
well this is what we do on a longer term
trajectory we have a purpose and passion
a real fight a real purpose in our lives
right so then the last thing is really
how we Bond all of these things affect
our hormones all of these things affect
our neurochemistry right and if we put
down the damn phone and we have more of
this culture this chemistry this
electricity right what this does for our
dopamine and our hormones right if
you're not bonding with people
right and you have a scarcity mindset
you're going to be in predominantly a
sympathetic State you're burning glucose
for fuel instead of fat instead of being
in a beta oxidation state right what you
need to do is put down the phone do this
sort of thing and all of these things so
you're like hey what do I do if you do
these things how much you want to bet
you're like holy [ __ ] I've never thought
for a minute that I could express what
I'm expressing now physically in
business as a partner as as as a partner
in business as a partner in relationship
you're going to be so much better again
you get better in life as a person you
get better in all your roles and goals
and it's like you have super powers
right so you just start doing these
things man and how much you want to bet
it's less effort than working out as
hard as you you're working out it's more
sustainable and it's infinitely scalable
in the sense that like you you said
you're 32. yeah you know if you do these
things you know the the 40 year old
version of you is gonna crush the 32
year old version and I'm sure that you
already know that from like a mental
social emotional standpoint especially
from a spiritual standpoint right but
from a physical standpoint you do these
things right all this stuff comes
together you know the the
um
I know that you said last question um
that's the answer to that does that does
that make sense kind of like do you do
chest days bicep days back days I want
to know like your workout routine like
okay I'm gonna get you yeah yeah the
fundamental thing is the fundamental
thing okay that's what I told you sure
um and then the supplemental thing is
getting into the gym it's one of the
ancestral tenants I do do stuff like
that
um so uh on Monday I call it leg day
predominantly squats okay
um and then in the afternoon I'm doing
some kind of metabolic condition
predominantly Sprints I'm never getting
on anything doing chronic cardio you're
not going to catch me doing a slow jog
doing a slow row if I get on the rower
the assault bike or the skierg I'm doing
15 20 second Sprints as hard as I can
I'll take a two minute break in between
and when you do that it's that that's
resistance right you're building
strength power explosivity and
hypertrophy into your metabolic
conditioning
so uh so on Monday early I do legs
emphasis on squat then I do metabolic
conditioning in the afternoon on Tuesday
I'm usually doing chest in the morning
sure back in the afternoon okay and then
Wednesday's uh I can't believe I'm gonna
tell you this that's been about an hour
doing chord work just doing setups ghd
unilateral carries like really crazy
things sure and uh and this is part of
like my psychosis like you guys I I
don't I've never said this before
sometimes I think I'm a little fat right
you're thinking it's crazy right listen
I get it yeah I I get on it I probably
should have said this on Diary of a CEO
but like you know I store my fat in my
love handles and I'm like [ __ ] man but
this is what I say if I do an hour of
core work on Wednesdays and an hour of
core work on Sundays which I do on my
rest day yeah I do those things right if
I can build up like from like I build my
ab muscles with heavy weights like doing
heavy things I'm like if I can do that
I can feel better like it's like it's
okay like if I had some fat around my
left hand look I'm okay with that
because here's the thing if I go into
calorie deficit and I really get lame my
my brain doesn't fight right and it's
too important for me to for my brain to
fire because the job we have to do but
if I can get myself into the gym for an
hour on my rest days and all I do is set
up some ghds and the crazy things I do
I'm like I can build my ab muscles so
big or or I gotta have implants or
whatever you know um so that's what I'll
do on Wednesdays on Thursdays I'll do
lower body again with an emphasis on
posterior chain so like today I did I
did a 500 pound deadlift
um I did a lot of deadlifts I did
reverse uh uh Romanian deadlifts I did
some ghd so I do a lot of that stuff in
the afternoon on Thursday I do another
metabolic conditioning and then on
Friday basically my Tuesday is also my
Friday just in the morning back in the
afternoon and then Saturday is Barbarian
what do you do if you travel it's not
like but how do you work out like a 500
pound deadlift if let's say you're at
the do you just find a gym so I bring my
weights with me
really how do you fly I don't think you
fly you drive right you're flying an
airplane
huh you do you just fly like a normal
plane you could take massive plates on
them we fly in like a citation or a
latitude or sovereign
you know so I take my weights with me if
for some reason like but you're staying
at like the penthouse like where do you
set that up yeah they set it up ahead of
time um I will say this I got the most
incredible assistant her name's Kimberly
I think she might be in the room
um I raised my voice a lot to her I
don't tell her how much I appreciate her
and how great but there's no possible
way we'd be here doing what we're doing
if I couldn't focus on what I need to
focus on I get to the penthouse suite
and all the weights are set up really
next to the office everything's already
there everything's perfect
perfect I got sets of dumbbells I got
bars I got machines in the penthouse
but the thing about this um if I don't
have to think about that at all right I
get to focus on the most important
things in my life I I have the most
incredible team that takes care of all
of that stuff right I mean we have liver
King Chef Lionel takes care of all the
food we've got Kimberly and Dan who's
the estate manager that takes care of
everything from a personal standpoint
sets up everything it's Flawless right I
mean we have so much help that we can
focus on what we can be the best in the
world at and so sometimes I've heard
people trying to give you guys advice
they're like hey get some help you know
hey what's the worst thing that could
happen if you do and they don't create
convincing value right and I always tell
people hey man you're going to come on
for 90 days give me convincing value
make it so easy for me sure right and if
you don't it's okay because we're gonna
it's a 90 day interview let's just know
we're going separate directions
afterwards unless you make it convincing
so go make it convincing yeah and then a
lot of people rise to the occasion and
if they don't hey cool we already had
our exit strategy we're going our
separate directions anyways and then you
get to see how you can scale and grow
because all you want to do is focus on
the things you can focus on yeah and how
much you want to bet it gives you the
free space in your head that you never
thought you had the free space in the
head because a lot of people talk about
like time right it's focus focus is
number one and then I believe it's time
after that and and you can focus on the
things you never thought you could focus
on when when you know you have this
incredible team around you now you can
focus on your why in the world and now
you can amplify that so deep you know we
talk about the 20 cent coffee right and
the avocado toast and and this is one
thing that at least I wanted to bring up
is like how do you grow and expand right
and have this Mega philosophy of
abundance while you're Contracting and
having that kind of scarcity at the same
time it's a legitimate question because
you know um I would really like to know
if you think it's possible to do the
same I do I've realized uh over these
last few months that I really enjoy
Simplicity I take a lot of Pride and low
overhead just me Jack Alex we know we
got a small team we're all friends
that's where I'm the happiest and so
everyone has told me you know scale do
this and that honestly I'm my happiest
just keeping it small and I think that's
where I found my Niche and it's going to
be different for everybody but for me I
really enjoy just that sort of Lifestyle
what's happy for you uh I would say just
getting to do what I want a day without
any obligation I always do the same
thing but if I don't have to do it it
just it makes me more open you know Tony
Robbins said that happiness is one word
it's progress
right so when I hear that people are
content they're happy doing the same
thing what they're doing I'm like are
you right because like if you can make
progress physically mentally
intellectually spiritually right
holistically and you grow like that you
know this is why we stay in the
penthouse suite the biggest Suite that
there is because I'm like I need room I
need room to grow to express my highest
and most dominant form and if you put me
in a 400 square foot cage like you know
that this doesn't feel right for me and
so I did want to bring this up yeah but
because
um because man I think that you guys
have something incredible going here and
I've been looking for this opportunity
and when um Steve will do it give Kyle
this necklace you know and then Kyle
looked at me and Kyle saw something in
me that I didn't see in myself and you
know that kind of leadership that kind
of recognition Mento meant the world to
me so I thought okay so how does this
thing go forward now and I didn't know I
thought a lot about it and he said hey
you keep this for a while you feel the
gravity of whatever this thing is and
what this is is abundance right I mean
this kind of necklace I had this thing
appraised you wouldn't believe this is a
six-figure necklace that this guy gave
to this guy Kyle from milk full sin
we're sharing a happy dance and for
whatever reason he looks over at me and
he says hey man you take this necklace
right and you wear for a while and I've
never seen him so serious he goes he
almost like pulled me by the color I
wasn't wearing he's like
um
you promised me you're gonna do that and
then you promise me you're gonna pay
forward right and again this is about
abundance and philosophy and spreading
this kind of message and so what I want
to do is I want to give it to you dude
are you are you sure I'm 100 am I like a
100 the reason why I'm such a hundred
percent is is in part because I'm so
convinced what I'm saying is accurate
yeah because my wife and I came from a
point of in our lives where the scarcity
mindset
changed our lives right because we're in
the single digit margin business for so
long and then we got down to one car and
it was simple right and and we were
happy it's what we called it right and
then what we figured out is um as we
started to Branch out more because we
got a little bit comfortable it's like
you know what we we have such a nice
cash Reserve now we have Assets in a way
that something catastrophic can happen
and now we're good forever and the
freedom that they gave us to go and
explore allowed us to find our true
cause in life and and I'm not expecting
to change your philosophy overnight sure
but I want you to be able to feel the
weight of this and I want you to be
encouraged you know to say
um you have the way that you want to be
but I want you to at least be encouraged
to to lean into that abundance a little
bit more and to just know you got
opposing forces sure and still keep keep
that one right it's still simple but
maybe maybe you could pay a little bit
more for that coffee sure next time and
lean into that abundance can we be good
on that yeah
are you serious five times at the hotel
like how do you take it off it wasn't
easy
um and here's the deal I'm not gonna put
it on my gosh but uh and here's the deal
I don't I don't wear this stuff right I
don't wear if you've ever seen me on a
podcast the only podcast it was delc
right so I really thought I like that
I'm glad you had the drink on milk by
the way yeah
it goes like that you just put it in
there I wore this today because I wanted
to give it to you because I didn't know
that [ __ ] now how do I know who to hand
it off to next you know you'll know
really here's the thing I had no idea I
had no idea but but just promise me that
sure and you're gonna do this oh my God
yeah Graham hold on to it for a little
while all right all right and then when
it's time I know that you're going to
give it to the person that deserves a
deal and here's the deal Jack
I got something for you bro oh you did I
was not I'm just happy for my buddy
great okay good because I was just
joking okay
I know it seriously but with all
seriousness I brought this for you no
you no you didn't listen it's really
special to me and I want to show you why
look at the back of that
no no no oh come on what's wrong with
you
so here's the thing
um it says loyalty and it's loyalty
above all
because wow that this watch represents
something incredibly important to me
there's an OG group of guys that took me
in when nobody would take me in and so I
had this the same watch main for this
group of guys that took me in when
nobody would take me in and when we
started this podcast I told you guys why
I'm so appreciative right I desperately
need invites like this I need these
sorts of platforms and and trust me when
I give this to you it's probably not
even for you but this is more for me
right and imagine how I feel right now
to be able to gift this to you guys and
also knowing right that the principle
behind here right is abundance it's
growth it's expansive right because
again what I say is you can't contract
and live a life of scarcity while being
abundant and growing and leaning into
these incredible things and the talent
that you guys have it's such a you're
expressing such a small fraction of it
and I can't wait to be plugged in to see
what you're doing down the road to do a
part two here all right so this is the
thing I wear a 20 Timex watch yeah I had
these lever King shorts made they're
cotton they're like ten dollars each I
had 500 of them made so I never have to
buy them again and um that's all I wear
I wear a 20 watch I wear 10 shorts I I
wear a hat I wear a hat
um and so I know you got a badass watch
and I know you got some guests on here
with like watches you know yeah like I'm
gonna wear my fanciest watch and I'm
wearing my necklace over here that's
crazy but lyric we could tell you before
before coming over here I looked in the
mirror I'm like oh my God I'm really
going to wear this and I thought about
Steve will do it and I thought about
Kyle and I thought about what this
stands for I thought about how important
this is and I thought why do I care how
I look when what this stands for you
know so much bigger than us right so we
have our whys in the world the kind of
good that we're doing
um I'm so what I said in the beginning
I'm so grateful that you guys had me on
the podcast because people are hurting
right there's something that they can do
today it's the nine ancestral tenants it
will change their lives tomorrow and it
costs nothing right this is what I want
to model teach and preach and and I
wanted to leave this you know in a way
that people will remember that is insane
I think Jack is still in disbelief still
waiting for the uh I can't believe it I
really can't I almost cried good I
actually almost cried that's it as soon
as he came in I'm like I did too and I
think that you're buddy has the same one
too right or he has a very similar
Submariner I'm not sure uh but here's
the thing that's nuts it's uh you know
you guys when there was the opportunity
I've never done a podcast like this
right I've done other mainstream
podcasts but I've never done a podcast
business oriented podcast sure and
there's so many people that are
interested you know in this category and
and the first time was like you know
what I have an entrepreneur like I'm an
Entre like I could talk about this I
don't have to really get ready for this
podcast I'm like I know this stuff
um and uh and then I realized like what
an incredibly important thing you know I
know that I can help spread a message
that's not just about how we achieve but
but you know again we got the science of
achievement the art of fulfillment I got
something that I want to say and you
guys gave me the platform to say this I
believe that the value is beyond
reciprocal I would say I got the Lions
share of it right and and then Alex
sharpen used to always say you know the
best way to get into momentum is to give
it to somebody else you guys know what
this stands for I know what you're going
to do with that I can't wait to see who
that lands on next no right who that
long lens on that's a lot of pressure it
is to see who gets this next that's what
I thought yeah I started writing down
all the names right and then I thought
you know what this has taken up a lot of
headspace and then I just settled on you
know what Kyle told me he's like you'll
know you'll know and then I just put in
the safe and I didn't know I had no idea
oh man that's crazy and then I knew yeah
I knew I'd want to run it by you before
I hand it off like just to make sure it
gets approval like up the up the chain
of command I I trust in the process 100
I thought I said the same thing yeah I'm
gonna ask Kyle what kind of stipulations
I was like hey people do it what kind of
stipulations are there you know
um and then I became so confident and I
became so clear and that this was the
right opportunity you know once again I
know my why in the world you know how
many people are going to hear this
because it's not just a mainstream
podcast where the the way I see this is
you have mega influencers you have
entrepreneurs right that are so dialed
into this that have teams right and so
to be able to affect people at that
level that are leading to affect people
at that level is a really big deal to me
yeah so how much you want to bet when
when it's time you don't run anything by
me you'll get a new one thank you man
the serious I'm blown away I'm still
waiting for like it's a prank yeah not a
fragrance
I can't even put it on Jack this is uh I
feel like I I feel like I put it on I
can help you let me show you uh real
quick actually just see if it fits you
first and if not I'll help you put it on
I think my wrists are a little smaller
than yours let me help you adjust it
real quick uh close on my inside because
the other day oh do you know how to do
it how you doing okay because it's
pretty cool um this part right here you
just pull this down and then it slides
back and forth in here you see that
yeah it's really really easy to do so
I'm just going to lock it again see if
that's but if that's not better you will
need an adjustment on the other side you
could always just take out one link if
you need to you might have to how long
have you had this why does it matter I'm
just I want to know the history of it
well the history is deep you know the
the history is what I told you is
um remember I told you when I was 15 the
bully had stopped it's because there was
a group of guys that took me in you know
and they cared for me and they loved me
and they saw something in me that I
didn't see to myself and uh and so I
said You know guys it's been decades
since I've seen these guys and I invited
them to liver King Ranch and we all had
to get together and I and and so I gave
all these guys the same watch and I was
like uh that's the history that's what
you need to know that's the history
behind it and and it's a special watch
to me and I know it's going to be
special to you you know and it means a
ton for me
oh my God that is nuts that is a good
looking watch too you you better
actually wear this watch all the time
Jack
I have to do something for you I have to
I want to do that yeah barbarians yes
we're committed to that yeah we are
we're committed I would love I would
love to be able to go to Texas and see
how you live for a weekend I'll get
there on a Friday and I want to live
like you for one day it's a full
Saturday I think that that would be an
incredible video an incredible yeah I
saw that yeah I saw it he came to do
that that guy's a machine that guy's so
impressive you know I'm so impressed um
his work ethic you know like what we
talk about man if you want an uncommon
life do uncommon things and sometimes
all you got to do let's work your ass
off yeah and and that guy is is great
his energy and he cut he came to do that
and I was like I'm gonna break him no
problem I had a little competition with
him I dominated him on all the
competitions but um but I would love for
you guys to come we're gonna do this and
we're gonna do Barbarian and we're gonna
hold each other accountable too yeah is
this something where I could come there
on a Saturday do the Barbarian on a
Sunday how much planning do I have to do
to do the Barbarian well what I'm gonna
have to do um I I have uh one of my best
guys my Korean
um he helps to send programs so that you
can do this some of the training for
barbarian ahead of time okay and if you
don't have the equipment we'll send you
the equipment and then we're going to
take it back afterwards yeah um but uh
but we're going to send you some of that
equipment so you don't just show up
completely unprepared right you'll do a
little bit of training we like to have
at least six weeks of training so we'll
triangulate a date we'll get a little
program together for you guys we'll send
you the implements and we'll come we'll
do that how much you want to bet I love
it when people come to visit me yeah but
because a lot of at first people like oh
there's another guy in the fitness
category right and and then I was like
oh my God please don't like pigeonhole
me in the fitness category and then Mark
Bell said hey the least impressive thing
about you is your physique and I know if
you come hang out with me and spend time
with me what you're going to say is the
least impressive thing is your physique
and your family is the most impressive
thing and I don't think that you can
have this kind of family you know unless
you're creating value in the world and
I'd love for us to spend some time
together and I would love for you guys
to see that sort of deal thank you so
much man oh yeah seriously I'm gonna
give you a hug after all this yes wow if
we're wrapping up there's something I
always say can I say it right now
absolutely okay the name is liver King
because liver is King liver King out I
love it oh my God thank you man thank
you so much this has been great